Guten Morgen Linus. Und hast du dir dein Demogeld schon abgeholt?
Vierhundertfünfzig Euro haben oder nicht haben? Natürlich.
Logbuch Netzpolitik mit der Folge zweihundertdreiundneunzig, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ich glaube zweihundertzweiundneunzig.
Erst zwei oder zwei, haben wir das letzte Mal zweimal zweiundneunzig gemacht. Nee, du hast recht. Zweihundertzweiundneunzig. Ähm vom.
Sonntag, den vierundzwanzigsten dritten zweitausendneunzehn finanziert.
Mit Google Geld, denn wir haben ja alle ähm schön Demogeld bekommen.
Aus aus unterschiedlichen Quellen war auf die, auf die Kralle und deswegen sind Thomas und ich jetzt hier mit neuen Apple Watches ausgestattet und Podcasten wie immer live in unsere Rechner.
Ja, was die dieser dieser hochfinanzierte ähm Netzpolitiklobbyismus. Die CDU hat da wirklich ein Schwarze getroffen. Also man merkt auch, dass die Argumente immer stichhaltiger werden.
Ja, das ist die äh äh stichhaltige Argumenteunion äh Deutschlands. Aber wir versuchen.
Es in der Reihenfolge grob zu machen, haben wir uns gerade geeinigt. Deswegen für diejenigen, die sich, die noch gar nicht wissen, wo sie die vierhundertfünfzig Euro herkriegen, das sagen wir euch im Laufe der Sendung, bleiben sie bitte dran.
Denn wir müssen erzählen, wie es in Brüssel war.
Genau, wir waren nämlich beide äh letzte Woche in Brüssel und äh haben da äh unterschiedliche Dinge getan, aber waren beide auch im EU-Parlament, wo glaube ich auch noch ein paar anderen Stellen.
Ich war auch in der Kommission und im Restaurant.
Wir wollten ja eigentlich auch dort Podcast. Ich hatte auch alles mitgeschleppt
Aber die Tage waren da einfach so lang und so erschlagend, dass wir das nicht geschafft haben uns überhaupt großartig zu sehen, ne? Deswegen sorry, dass wir hier mal wieder.
Ähm versagt haben und kein Logbuchletzpolitik live aus Brüssel mehr gemacht haben. Holen wir aber hiermit nach.
Gut, also ich war mit äh meinem Kollegen Bernhard Heide in Brüssel
und äh wir waren dort, um eigentlich Kinken zu putzen, um mit den Abgeordneten zu sprechen und eben noch möglichst viele von denen zu überzeugen, gegen Artikel dreizehn und elf zu stimmen
Ähm und das war eigentlich wahnsinnig spannend. Wir man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass Europaparlament ist um einiges offener als äh sicher der österreichische Nationalrat und ich glaube auch der deutsche Bundestag. Ähm man muss natürlich schauen, schauen, wie man zu seine Termine
kommt aber als einzelner interessierter Bürger, hat man da eine Chance
mit dem Abgeordneten selbst oder mit den Assistenten eine Stunde zu bekommen und dann wirklich auch über die Inhalte zu reden.
Und und die die spannendsten Gespräche waren eigentlich die mit
Den Menschen, die sich noch nicht entschieden hatten, weil wer den Pleitscher unterschrieben hat, äh also Pletsch zwanzig neunzehn Punkt EU, die Kampagne, die wir machen, der ist eh schon klar auf unserer Seite.
Wohl nicht mehr besucht, oder?
Nee, also nur die, die in der Mitte sind, das waren eh noch fünfhundert Leute, äh, mit denen, wo wir Meetings angefragt haben, personalisiert und dann eben je nach Rücklauf nochmal verfeinert und insgesamt, glaube ich, zwanzig Meetings gehabt haben in diesen drei, vier Tagen,
ja und äh dann das sind dann wirklich lange Tage. Aber ich würde gerne noch auf ein paar Argumente der der Gegenseite auch angehen, um die zu.
Ich würde einmal ganz kurz sagen, das ist ja sowieso einfach, was ihr euch da angetan habt, das ist ja.
Also da muss man wirklich mal sagen, das ist ja ein, das ist eine Knochenarbeit und das ist ähm
Weit über das Selbstverständliche hinaus, ne und äh wirklich mal mein.
Vollen Respekt dafür. Ich weiß nicht, ob da in irgendeiner in irgendeiner Airbnbude oder sogar gehaust ne und euch die die Tage von oben bis unten voll gemacht als Lobbyisten mehr oder weniger in eurer Freizeit. Das ist schon echt ein ziemlich krasses Engagement. Wirk
vielen, vielen Dank.
Wobei muss sozusagen für uns ist es keine Freizeit, sondern da ist halt schon für für uns ist es ja wirklich Beruf. Also bei unserem Verein ist es so, dass
Jetzt paar of the Deal, wenn wir die Chance haben, das Ding zu zu retten, dann machen wir alles, was es dafür brau,
die Pletschkampagne ist dafür entstanden und natürlich dann mit so einer Kampagne hast du auch ein anderes Mandat und kriegst auch Termine mit Leiten, die sich sonst nie mit dich treffen würden. Und.
Okay, verstehe.
Sozusagen ein bissel die Pflicht, die damit kommt. Ähm und ja, aber.
Also ich kann nur sagen, wer ich würde, nachdem ich jetzt ein nicht so oft in Brüssel war. Ähm und natürlich heiße ich das alles gut, aber einfach nur von dem, was ich mit meiner Zeit, ob also für mich ist ja eh alles äh ich nehme.
Das meiste als Freizeit war. Ähm.
Ich würde viel, vieles andere machen. Wenn ich's irgendwie vermeiden könnte, mir das anzutun. Aber meine Erfahrungsbericht kommt ja gleich.
Ähm ja ich ich wollte noch kurz über die Argumente äh sp
die, die man dort so hört und das was am häufigsten kommt ist natürlich die armen Armen, Künstler und Musiker und die müssen endlich besser bezahlt werden. Das ist.
Ja, habt ihr ja nicht wieder gesprochen, oder.
Natürlich nicht, weil äh das ist auch ganz wichtig äh wir sind keineswegs
gegen das Urheberrecht als solches. Ich glaube, es braucht ganz dringend ein urheberrecht, dass diesen Interessensausgleich zwischen ähm kreativ schaffenden
und Gesamtgesellschaft und den Verwertern und Verlagen, die da dazwischen stehen, herstellt. Ähm nur ist
da wird halt oft immer so der kleine arme Künstler
ja, der wenig Einkommen hat als Beispiel genommen, auch wenn das Gesetz auch jetzt mal abgesehen von Artikel elf und dreizehn. Eigentlich nur für die großen Künstler oder eben auch die großen Verlage geschrieben ist und ähm deswegen gibt's auch viele
Torenstimmen zum Beispiel, die sich Göttin Joysan zu diesem Gesetz und die um ihre Rechte auch umgefallen sind. Ein modernes Urhebervertragsrecht, also da wo Urheber mit ihren Verlagen verhandeln und
vielleicht bei transparenz über die Einnahme mit ihren Werken haben wollen und vielleicht auch nachverhandeln wollen, wenn das Buch, was sie geschrieben haben, Bestseller wird. Das ist alles großteils rausgeflogen oder massiv abgeschwächt worden.
Und das heißt da ist auch der finale Text der jetzt zur Abstimmung vorliegt um eine Geschlechter als das was noch im September abgestimmt wurde.
Ähm und das ist auch so ein gutes Argument. Also die arme Künstler, die sind hier eigentlich nicht mehr die Haupt äh bevorzugten von der ganzen Reform. Ähm.
Ähm gibt's trotzdem noch gute Aspekte äh in freier Werknutzung und so, da gibt's ein paar gute Aspekte drinnen, aber wie gesagt, der große Fokus liegt auf elf und dreizehn und,
bringt mich auch zum nächsten Hauptargument der Gegenseite. Google muss endlich zahlen. Google muss endlich äh.
Also da da gibt es einen enormen äh Regulierungshunger äh in der Politik und ich meine da würden wir auch immer sofort zustimmen. Ich meine als Datenschutzorganisation wenn man
versteht, dass Google hier wirklich mit seinem Monopol ähm sehr viel Schindluder betreibt, seine Steuern nicht bezahlt und äh keiner weiß so wirklich, welche Lizenzvereinbarungen es zwischen YouTube und der Gamer gibt,
da ist ja Stillschweigung drüber vereinbart, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass man da definitiv noch mehr hätte rausholen können,
Das sind alles Punkte, wo ich glaube, äh so ein Gesetz, dass einfach nur Google Geld wegnimmt und an die Künstler verteilt, äh wird einstimmig.
Wieder einstimmig im Europaparlament angenommen.
Aber ähm das Problem ist doch bei diesem Gesetz, das ist doch ähnlich wie beim Leistungsschutzrecht, die letztendlich jetzt genau googeln, nicht besonders hat.
Deswegen stehen ja auch äh immer mehr Start-ups auf, also ähm es ist ja.
Also mit mit anderen Worten um jetzt, um jetzt kurz die Argumente zu zählen, die armen Künstler und Musiker sagen wir
Ja genau, deswegen muss diese Reform anders sein. Google muss endlich zahlen, sagen wir, ja genau, deswegen muss diese Reform anders sein. Ähm was gibt's noch für für spannende Ausreden.
Also wenn man dann in die Details von Artikel dreizehn geht und sagt so, okay, aber
Dieser Filter funktioniert einfach nicht und schau mal, wir haben da enorme Kollateralschäden und du gibst Google noch mehr Macht, weil die Kleinen würden so einen Filter nicht bauen können, da kommt dann immer.
Wir schaffen doch hier nur einen rechtlichen Grundsatz. Wir als Stabus in der Liga Prince Bo. Ja? Also,
alle technischen Fragen wird immer nur mit rechtlichen Dingen geantwortet. Das sieht man sowohl bei Axel Voss, als auch bei vielen französischen Abgeordne.
Gerade bei den Franzosen ist das so die die sind wirklich verloren in diesem Dossier. Also in Frankreich gibt es Pascale Partei die,
kritisch ist gegenüber diesem Gesetz. Ich glaube, wir haben nur eine grüne Abgeordnete bisher, die äh den Pletscher unterschrieben hat und äh auch wenn man da mit Assistenten spricht, auch wenn die jünger sind,
da ist einfach eine gänzlich andere Geisteshaltung als bei anderen, allen anderen Ländern da. Es äh so ein dann nochmal spannend in der französisch sprechenden Teil von Belgien, wo äh,
Das ist sozusagen ein bissel die Kippe ist und da da hat man beide Strömungen und das ist nicht so ganz klar, wer jetzt gewinnt. Ähm aber das ist äh der da wird einfach auf die technische Kritik überhaupt nicht eingegangen, sagen wir mal,
einfach, dass wenn man im Gesetz Dinge reinschreibt, die
Technik da schon irgendwie erfüllen wird ähm und und dass man aber kann fliegen das Auto ins Gesetz schreiben kann, wenn's die Technik dafür nicht gibt, das wird ein noch nicht wahrgenommen.
Um jetzt mal vorsichtig darauf einzugehen. Ich weiß nicht,
Also dieses Argument habe ich auch sehr sehr häufig gehört von unterschiedlichen Personen auch in meinen zwei Tagen, die ich nur in Brüssel war. Hm und.
Erstmal ist das kein so,
Also zumindest ist das Argument eines worüber man mal nachdenken muss. Was hieße das denn, wenn sie spezifische Techniken vorschreiben würden, was sie hier natürlich eigentlich tun, ne? Aber natürlich ist es schon klar, dass man irgendwie einen einen gesetzlichen Rahmen.
Schaffen sollen die Regulierungen nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen soll. Und ich glaube mir ist auch sehr klar geworden aus unseren Gesprächen das was die.
Eigentlich klären wollen. Ähm was worum es denn eigentlich geht.
Ist dieser auch hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik damals schon sehr regelmäßig behandelte Streit zwischen der GEMA und YouTube.
Ja? Wo es letztendlich nämlich also da ist das ist quasi genau das, was da passiert, was da passiert ist. Äh Gemer hat gesagt, hier YouTube, ähm zahl uns für die Musik,
die unter Umständen in den Videos stattfindet. YouTube hat gesagt ja ich von mir aus, wir haben hier
relativ kleines Budget, das könnten wir euch dafür zur Verfügung stellen, hat die GEMA gesagt, nein, wir haben hier die GEMA-Tarife, die bekanntermaßen ähm
ebenso recht ähm weltfremd sind und dann hat YouTube gesagt, ja okay, dann lösch, dann sperren wir eben eure Videos und machen,
drauf ein Sperrhinweis, wo einfach steht dieses können wir euch nicht zeigen wegen der GEMA. Ja? Was dazu geführt hat, dass endlos viele YouTube,
äh Zuschauer ähm angepisst waren auf die Gamer und wenn ich mich nicht recht täusche.
Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ähm hat auch YouTube dafür nachher vor Gericht verloren. Ja, der wurde dieser Text, dieser Sperrtafeln.
Wurde als nicht korrekt äh korrekte Darstellung zurückgewiesen, aber interessanterweise haben wir hier genau gesehen, dass nämlich YouTube klar verweigert hat und gesagt hat, na ja okay, dann eben nicht. Und irgendwie versuchen die jetzt,
so meine Erfahrung oder meine
Meine Interpretation, irgendwie einen legislativen Rahmen zu schaffen, der dafür sorgen würde, dass die Gamer sollte sich diese Situation wiederholen, einen längeren Hebel bekommt.
Denen ist nur nicht klar, dass sie das mit dieser ähm mit dieser Direktive nicht erreichen.
Aber die Idee ist ja erstmal nicht. Also ich find's ganz interessant, also die Idee ist ja erstmal nicht so schlecht.
Ähm ich ich glaube äh,
Artikel dreizehn hat grob zwei Seiten, ja? Es ist eine ist die Frage der Lizenzierung und ich glaub da gibt es ein ein Gangbaren Weg wie man
mit äh äh diesem, diesem Finanzierungsaufkommen umgehen kann und dann gibt's eben diese Haftungsfrage, die automatisch zu den Filtern führt. Ja, ähm aber
das bringt mich genau zu einem der nächsten Hauptargumente. Äh es kann nicht sein, dass es ein ein Geschäftsmodell, das auf Diebstahl aufbaut, dass wir das zulassen, ja? Also man sagt einfach so
Hier wird Geschäft gemacht mit den Inhalten anderer und äh da deswegen müssen wir hier einen Riegel vorschieben.
Auch von mehreren Leuten gehört.
Also ich das sind das ist doch auch wieder so ein spannender Talking Point, oder? Weil ich meine von also von Diebstahl, ich welches.
Die Leute, die solche Sätze sagen, ohne da jetzt irgendjemanden wörtlich zu zitieren, ne? Glänzen jetzt nicht unbedingt da damit, dass sie besonders viel Kenntnis hätten von den Plattformen, die sie da regulieren.
Und da irgendwie zu sagen, dass also spezifisch jetzt Google oder YouTube zu unterstellen, dass es ein Geschäftsmodell ist, was auf Diebstahl basiert.
Also
dem Argument, es gibt halt einige Probleme damit. Das eine ist ähm äh was hier als Diebstahl bezeichnet, äh wird, wäre in den USA in vielen Fällen von Fair Use Schranken.
Also einer ganz normalen privaten, nicht kommerziellen Nutzung von urheberrechtlichen Werken, wo keine Gewinnabsicht,
und insofern ist das unter der Schranke, wo äh man wirklich mit Urheberrecht tätig wird, kann sein, dass dann Tickdown passiert, aber das ist eben ein Notdisuntick-Dun-Verfahren, nicht präventiv, schon mal alles filtern, sondern man muss sich erst melden.
Und ähm das ist schon mal die eine Frage mit dem Diebstahl und dann gibt's da die zweite Seite. Ähm es es sind auch wahnsinnig viele.
Menschen, die auf YouTube Dinge hochladen, selbst auch Kreative, selbst auch Schaffende, ähm die, die hier Inhalte produzieren
und die pollen überhaupt nicht vor in diesem Gesetz. Also alles, was User Tourrated Content ist eigentlich so der Teil, wo sich die Welt gedreht hat, seit dem letzten EU-Urheberrechtsgesetz zweitausendeins
Der fehlt hier komplett, weil die Menschen, die das geschrieben haben, auch nicht äh so gedacht haben, dass wir hier wirklich mal an der Lebensrealität versucht, äh Regelungen zu erfinden.
Also ähm aber das zieht sich sowieso durch das ganze Gesetzlager. Ähm und äh
ja, dann ist die eigentliche dritte Frage
eben wirklich diese Lizenzierung. Also ich glaube auch, dass es hier eine Möglichkeit gäbe, wo man wirklich sagt, das ist äh die Inhalte anderer, die auch wirklich ähm,
kommerzialisiert werden und die sozusagen auch wirklich den Kern von dem Ausmachen nicht ich habe ein Forum,
dort wird dann ein Text gepostet, äh der ein Gedicht ist, der äh unter jemanden zu Urheberrecht in täglicher Weise fällt. Das ist alles viel zu breit gedacht, in viel zu vielen Mediengattungen,
und auch für Plattformen, die dies eigentlich die eigentlich nicht abhängig sind von dieser Art von urheberrechtlichen Inhalten,
Und was dahinter steht, ist auch äh diese ganze Debatte um den Value Gup. Das hört man auch oft von der Gegenseite, dass äh man bei Spotify, so und so viel
äh Cent verdient pro Stream und bei YouTube seien es so viel weniger
Ähm dazu ist mal zu sagen, dass auch Spotify viel zu wenig zahlt für die Streams
da gibt's grade anhängige Verfahren in den USA wo die Musiker dort versuchen vierzig Prozent mehr zu bekommen. Apple Music ist drauf eingestiegen, die anderen,
klagen jetzt alle ähm und äh da muss man auch sehen so YouTube ist halt auch irgendwie mehr als ein Streaming-Service. Das ist.
Was was meinst du mit Apple Music ist darauf eingestiegen, also die haben gesagt, okay, hier habt ihr eure vierzig Prozent, oder?
Also das heißt oh okay, interessant, das heißt also wenn ich wenn ich fair Musik streaming machen will, dann bin ich gerade besser bei Apple als bei Spotify.
Ja, wobei ob
dass diese Regelung in den USA auch für unseren Europakraft weiß ich nicht. Ähm nur ja, also es geht schon in die Richtung, das sind halt ähm Riesenbiers zwischen äh globalen Konzernen und und lokalen Verwertungsgesellschaften. Und.
Warum warum aber sorry, wenn ich da nochmal kurz reingrätsche Thomas? Das fände ich mal wirklich spannend. Also das wäre für mich tatsächlich für mich sofort ein ein primäres Sales-Argument, bei der Auswahl meines Streaming-Dienstes.
Das wäre echt einfach mal. Warum also warum schaffen die da nicht überhaupt mal Transparenz? Ist mir so ich bin vielleicht auch zu zu äh zu wenig daran interessiert. Ähm.
Aber das wäre eigentlich, wenn sie das bewerben würden, ja, sagen hier, übrigens Apple zahlt so und so viel Prozent Spotify, nur so und so viel würde ich sofort sagen, okay, nehme ich den anderen.
Überall alles.
Ja und auch einfach zu wissen, okay, von meinen zehn Euro im Monat, an welcher Künstler es jetzt, wie viel davon gegangen? Das würde ich wahnsinnig gerne wissen
und diese Transparenz haben wir heute halt leider nicht
Ähm aber genau aus den Argumenten, die du nennst, äh habe ich mir Netflix geklickt, habe ich mir ein Musikstreaming-Dienst geklickt, weil
in Wirklichkeit wollen die Leute ja bezahlen. Das ist ja der Witz bei dem ganzen Piraterie-Argument. Sobald du Menschen eine legale Möglichkeit gibst
Menschen wollen für Kultur zahlen. Wenn man eine Band, einen Film, irgendein kreatives Werk schätzt, dann will man das auch ausdrücken
Und äh es gibt keine Gratiskultur, außer es ist der einfache der einzige dankbare Weg überhaupt an diese Kultur zu kommen.
Nächstes gegen Argument
auch wieder ein ganz schön dummes Tweez kommen, alle aus den USA, also alle Tweets, die zu diesem Thema im Protest gegen Artikel dreizehn formuliert sind, sollen alle aus den USA kommen.
Passiert auf einer ähm Studie, da verlinken wir auch nochmal an die Bankingartikel, ähm die die methodologisch extrem unsorber war, was die gemacht haben ist einfach bei allen Twitter-Profilen,
keine Location angegeben haben, die folgten sie den gesamten Twitter-Account auf Washington, die sie in den USA
und das ist natürlich so ein grober Schnitzer, wo du dann irgendwie Julia Reder und andere Abgeordneten des Europaparlaments werden dann als amerikanischer Meinung qualifiziert. Und äh die die haben hier extrem unsauber gearbeitet.
Auch dann, ja.
Also das Ding äh ist ist aber immer noch eines der Argumente, die man hört, wenn man mit Abgeordneten spricht.
Ist das nicht dieser Artikel, der äh äh ohnehin von so einem Urheberrechtslobbyisten geschrieben wurde in der Fahrt.
Ja, aber bei dem
FAZ, das ist nochmal ein eigenes Thema, wie sich hier Verlage derzeit. Äh im Grunde verbrennen die den Boden unserer Demokratie, dass man, dass man als als Medium das eigentlich
Das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung genießt so einseitig und tendenziös bewichtet, wie die FAZ im Moment oder auch Bild. Dass das ist äh,
Ich glaub denen ist auch nicht bewusst, wie viel Schaden sie da gerade erreicht.
Äh die FAZ äh also ja klar die FAZ hat gerecht üble Beiträge dazu veröffentlicht die dann immer schön als Meinung gekennzeichnet waren ne. Ähm.
Jetzt gut bei uns kommen irgendwie Axel Force auch nicht unbedingt zu Wort, ja? Ähm
Wobei ich gleich erklären musste, das habe ich auf jeden Fall schon mal vorweg, der wollte auch nicht.
Ich bin ja ähm da komme ich ja immer gleich nochmal zu. Okay, aber das kommt, dieses mit den äh Detweds kommen alle aus den USA, das ist einfach also ja, das ist so erbärmlich und so so schlecht und so falsch.
Deswegen wundert es mich so, dass man das immer noch hört im Parlament. Also da da ist die Informationslage halt auch sehr ungleich verteilt.
Ja, also ich ich glaube einfach guck mal selbst ich kann mir nicht,
ganz erklären,
Warum ausgerechnet dieses Thema jetzt so hochgekocht ist, ne? Es gibt irgendwie unterschiedliche äh potenzielle Thesen dazu. Man kann irgendwie sagen, ja, das waren Hits von mir aus die,
Weil YouTube
ähm Stars, die sonst eben was anderes machen, mobilisiert haben. Ähm man könnte sagen, vielleicht weil's gute Kampagnen gab, man könnte sagen, weil äh,
Was weiß ich, das Thema so lange beschäftigt ist, weil man könnte auch sagen, Copyright ist einfach irgendwas, was den Leuten ans Herz geht, weil sie ihre Creator mögen. Ich meine, Copyright hat,
in der Netzpolitik,
Schon Tradition als mit das größte Thema, ja? Wir haben eine Piratenpartei, die ähm hier auch in Deutschland enorme Erfolge hatte. Also das könnte alles sein.
Aber so richtig fragt man sich, es gab ja andere Themen, die die EU in aller Ruhe durch,
führen konnte, ja? Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die sich auch denken bei der Schierenmenge an Gesetzesform. Ähm Julia sprach ja davon, dass da irgendwie,
in so einem Plenumstermin, da gehen hundert, hundert so Dinger durch, ne? Hundert Abstimmungen oder so. Und auf einmal kocht ihr eins um die Ohren.
Ähm dass die dann versuchen, irgendwelche Erklärungen dafür zu finden. Und die sind natürlich teilweise ein bisschen sch.
Ja wobei ich will da kurz einhaken, also ähm
da gibt's natürlich mehrere Antworten drauf, ist so jetzt so viele Menschen sich bei dem Thema engagieren und nicht bei äh ich weiß nicht, E-Priver ist die Verordnung. Wäre genauso ein wichtiges Thema gewesen. Aber äh
hier ist halt schon da, dass es eine Weichenstellung,
Wenn wir Uploadfilter verlieren, dann werden wir Uploadfilter ähm künftig auf so gut wie allen Plattformen äh haben, um.
Das was heute vor Gericht passiert, schon mal präventiv ähm in den Armen der Plattform machen zu lassen. Davon bin ich sehr fest überzeugt bei einer anstehenden
Reform von ähm der E-Commerce Directive, da wird das äh sehr stark irgendwie ausschlaggebend sein, in welche Richtung die geht. Und ähm im Grunde ist es die Frage, wollen wir Netz, dass äh mal prinzipiell im der,
dem Freiheitsgedanken folgt, wo wir uns erst nach dem Blödsinn passiert ist, um solche Dinge kümmern oder wollen wir präventiv so viel wie möglich dicht machen, verlieren damit vielleicht Vielfalt und Freiheit.
Aber dafür haben wir mehr Ordnung und mehr Struktur. Das ist äh wieso viele in der Netzpolitik, ich kenne eigentlich keine NGO, die europäisch arbeitet, nicht schon seit Jahren sagt, das ist eigentlich das wichtigste Thema
Und wieso das jetzt in der Masse angekommen ist, das ist halt einfach wie bei Aqua damals eine ein sich verselbstständigender Prozess. Ähm ich hatte jetzt auch eben,
Vielen Abgeordneten auch in Österreich zu tun und was dir die sagen ist bei jedem einzelnen Wahlkampftermin kommt dieses Thema. Sobald du in der Schulklasse gehst,
zwei oder drei Mal eine Frage nach Artikel dreizehn gestell,
Und das ist auch ein Lobbydruck, der da von Kindern und Jugendlichen kommt, ja. Das ist nie unländlich äh Fridays for the Future und der Klimabewegung gerade ähm und und es hat ja auch eine Generationenkomponente,
die Axel Voss und Günther Oettinger werden genauso leider leben können und denen wird nichts fehlen, wenn Uploadfilter kommen. Für die jungen Menschen, die heute im Internet ihr,
äh Leben leben, ihre Freunde treffen, ihre Informationen finden und vielleicht sogar selber kreativ sind, für die ist das ein Makrobreak-Moment.
Die stehen jetzt auf. Das ist glaube ich, was hier,
auch passiert und ich meine, auch wenn man sich anschaut, wer die Demos organisiert in ganz Europa. Das sind Leute, die wir jetzt äh in in irgendwie weiß nicht viel hundertvier in Brüssel oder auf der Republika oder vielleicht auch auf dem CTC-Kongress so noch nicht gesehen haben. Das ist wie bei.
Ja, also zumindest.
Tschuldigung, da würde ich widersprechen.
Jahr in Berlin äh gut halten, dass es nochmal ein großer Ausnahmefall, aber in dem Ganzen weiß nicht, den fünfzig anderen deutschen Städten. Und äh ich weiß nur, dass es in in
Wien und ich glaube auch in Salzburg so war, dass das halt wie bei Akta damals aus einer Ecke kam, mit der keiner gerechnet hat und dann hast du halt irgendwie ähm,
Zwölfjährige, die die Anfragen, ob du die Demo nicht anmelden kannst, weil sie dürfen das noch nicht. Ähm und,
Weißt du, da dass die wir kommen noch zu den Demonstrationen. Wir nehmen gerade sehr viel vorweg. Ähm ein letztes Argument, das ich noch bringen will.
Filter haben eine neunundneunzigprozentige Erfolgsrate, also worüber regt ihr euch auf? Ähm.
Wurde gebrach.
Dass es äh eben vor allem ein Argument äh dass.
Nicht der Praxistest hält, wenn man weiß, irgendwie so bei hundert Millionen Videos heißt das eine Million wird falsch erkannt, wird also im Zweifelsfall auch fälschlicherweise runtergenommen, auch von
dem der neunundneunzig Millionen, die da richtig gerade waren, ähm die Erkennung sagt nichts über die Legalität aus. Ich kann immer noch unter einer,
Schranke fallen, es kann immer noch ein Zitat oder eine Parodie sein
und dadurch ist diese Erfolgsrate auch wenn sie denn wirklich so hoch wäre, um einiges größer. Und die komplette Zahl ist nochmal zu hinterfragen, weil diese neunundneunzig Prozent äh kommen doch nur Studien für Musik,
Wenn man da wirklich mit äh Audibisuellenmedien arbeitet oder eben auch noch Text mit einrechnet, was alles verlangt wird von den Plattformen, äh kommt man eher zu Erkennungsraten von sechzig, siebzig Prozent.
Abgesehen davon werde ich nicht müde darauf hinzuweisen, wenn jemand von einem Detektionsmechanismusfilter sonst etwas irgendetwas erkennen diagnostizieren oder sonstigem redet, dann gibt es nicht nur
einen Wert, der die Güte dieses Filters beschreibt, sondern zwei. Und diese beiden Werte sind.
Sensitivität und Spezifität mit anderen Worten, einmal die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn ein.
Was weiß ich, wenn das zu erkennende erkannt werden sollte und es erkannt wurde, mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit ist es wirklich darin gewesen.
Das wäre die ähm.
Sorry, jetzt komm. Jetzt komme ich selber durcheinander. Also ähm Sensitivität heißt, es ist tatsächlich.
Etwas vorhanden, ja? Also du hast hier den das Werk, welches du erkennen sollst, ja? Mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit erkennst du es auch? Das ist die Sensitivität
und dann gibt es noch die Spezifität, die quasi der umgekehrte Fall ist wenn du etwas erkannt hast.
Mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit ist es das auch tatsächlich
ja? Das sind diese, also klassisch wird sowas mit ähm irgendwelchen ähm Diagnose äh Geschichten für Krankheiten gemacht, ja, wo man dann sagt, okay, dieser Test,
hat irgendwie eine Sensitivität von.
Äh neunzig Prozent und eine Spezifität von vierzig Prozent. Beispielsweise, ja? Das hieße dann, wenn du die Krankheit hast, wird er dir zu neunzig Prozent aussagen, dass du sie hast
Es bleiben aber zehn Prozent übrig, dass du krank bist und der sagt dir aber nein, ja. Und umgekehrt, wenn er es dir aussagt.
Du hast diese Krankheit und die.
Spezifität wäre in diesem Beispiel jetzt nur vierzig Prozent, dann hieße das, dass du obwohl dich der Test als krank markiert oder dir ausweist, dass du diese Krankheit hast ähm
Hättest du sie immer noch nur zu vierzig Prozent so ein so wird natürlich so ein Test nicht zugelassen, aber ich erwarte.
In einer informierten Debatte, insbesondere, wenn da Menschen sitzen und sagen, pass mal auf mit diesen Filtern. Das gibt Overblocking, dann will ich nicht.
Dass ähm Sensitivitätsargument hören, sondern das Spezifitätsargument. Und das hast du ja hier nicht.
Du hast ja äh Filter haben neunundneunzig Prozent Erfolgsrate, was soll das überhaupt für einen Erfolg sein, ja? Die Frage ist, ähm was sind die, was passiert mit den.
Mit denen äh wo sie den äh also wird etwas ähm falsch erkannt zu haben überhaupt auch als Misserfolg gewertet und das ist ja dann hier nicht der Fall.
Ja äh ich ich will noch von einem äh Meeting erzählen, das ich hatte äh und zwar mit ähm Philipp Lambert.
Der ist ähm der Chef der grünen Gruppe im Europaparlament aus Belgien, an dem auch Fakrophon, also äh der kennt beide Debatten
Und äh ist dafür bekannt, dass er einen äh großen Humor hat und hat ähm macht sowas öfters. Er hat uns eingeladen, gemeinsam mit sechs Vertretern der Gegenseite
und äh das heißt du hast ja irgendwie so sechs Leiter von der Musikindustrie und mein Kollege Bernhard und ich und dann gehen gehen die mal so rein um
und wir haben so richtig schön Boomen First und dann erzählen die sehr offen
Ohne dass sie wissen, wer da eigentlich gerade im Raum ist. Das war auch sehr spannend. Die wissen natürlich auch, die Musikindustrie, die reden jetzt mit einem Grünen, der es tendenziell nicht auf ihrer Seite, aber trotzdem ähm scheinen die, zumindest, was sie gesagt haben
ist es auch sehr knapp aus ihrer Sicht. Ähm es ist auch so, dass ähm
Zieht diesen Protest spüren, sowohl die Blackouts wie die Demos und eben auch den Pletsch. Das haben sie von sicher selber genannt
und äh ja für sie ist halt auch Artikel dreizehn Grad so der ähm der Bruchpunkt
Also sie ankt eine Kompromissbereitschaft ist da keineswegs ersichtlich, sondern ähm für die geht es ganz klar um diese Haftungsfrage und um die Filter
ist das primäre Anliegen zumindest so von der Musikindustrie und das ist ja auch die einzige, die noch übrig geblieben ist. Auch die Filmindustrie hat sich ja schon distanziert zum Teil von diesen Gesetzesvorhaben.
Die Musikindustrie ist da immer noch ganz massiv dahinter, die Lobbyisten, die denen wir da gegenüber sitzen, ähm, waren handwerklich auch wahnsinnig gut, also sowas hab ich selten gesehen, irgendwie so fünf Sprachen sprechend und
sehr gezielt auch in ihrer Rhetorik. Aber ja da
Werden wir später auch nochmal drauf kommen, wenn wir über das Demogeld sprechen. Aber das ist halt so auch die Gegenseite, die dir die ganze Zeit schon
operiert und mit den Leuten spricht. Ähm, die Zivilgesellschaft kommt ja vielleicht so in der Woche vor der Abstimmung, vielleicht mal vorbei.
Und äh der hatte also den Humor, dass dir quasi das ihr da saßt und die gegenseitig die Argumente gehört habt.
Also die haben euch gehört und ihr habt die gehört und dann konnte man mal sehen wer die anderen düsteren Männer sind oder Frauen gab's da Frauen, nee, ne? Urüber rechtes? Ja auch.
Doch äh ja das das war einigermaßen gemischt und es geht halt so rein, äh Lambe stellt schnelle Fragen an die Leute und sie müssen sofort antworten ähm und wenn er keine gute Antwort hast, dann sagt er dir das auch direkt ins Gesicht.
Und dann am Ende lehnt er sich zurück und lass die Leute mehr oder weniger miteinander streiten.
Ja, das hätten andere auch mal machen können.
Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich besser gewesen als viele andere Ausschusssitzungen. Aber du warst ja auch in Brüssel erzählen.
Tja, also ich war bei der.
Ich war dort, äh muss man ja erstmal offenlegen auf äh Einladung der EU-Kommission, die,
den Flug und das Hotel sowie
ein Mittag und ein Abendessen bezahlt hat, was das insgesamt gekostet hat, weiß ich nicht, aber ich würde schätzen, irgendwo zwischen fünfhundert und.
Tausend Euro ähm wäre jetzt vorsichtig meine Schätzung, ich weiß nicht genau die Flüge.
Sind unterschiedlich teuer Hotelaufenthalte auch, aber dieses Hotel war sehr nah an der Kommission, also wahrscheinlich ähm.
Aber es teurer als die Ausstattung, es hätte vermuten lassen. Ähm das muss ich als erstes dazu sagen. Diese EU äh diese Kommission veranstaltet, die haben da unterhalten natürlich Personen für Presse, Arbeit und Veröffentlichkeitsarbeit,
die hier im weitesten Sinne.
Dem Ziel untergeordnet sind oder dem das Ziel verfolgen die Öffentlichkeit über die Vorgänge.
In Brüssel zu informieren. Ist ja auch richtig. Es ist ja ein viel bemängeltes oder viel besprochenes Defizit, das insgesamt in der.
In der Europäischen Union über die.
Herrscht in der Kenntnis über die Vorgänge dort, ja? Und da werden dann eben relevante Veröffentlichungen ähm eingeladen, doch dort mal zwei Tage Hintergrundgespräche zu führen.
Das ist in meinen Augen natürlich auch schon der äh der größte ähm Pferdefuß an dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, denn ähm.
Wir haben dort.
Ausschließlich ähm Hintergrundgespräche geführt und Hintergrundgespräch heißt ähm in diesem Fall, dass die Gespräche fast alle.
Of the Record waren mit anderen Worten, wir dürfen nicht daraus zitieren. Das hat Vorteile, das so zu machen.
Ist aber natürlich spezifisch bei den Themen ähm Urheberrecht, ja, wenn jetzt irgendwie die Abstimmung
Eine Woche später ist und du Termine mit Julia Reder und Axel Voss hast. Jetzt kommen die Schlauen und sagen, Moment mal, das ist aber EU-Parlament. Ja, wir haben einen Nachmittag im EU-Parlament gemacht, den Rest der Zeit fahren wir.
Mit der Kommission da beschäftigt. Ähm!
Dann ist das natürlich ein bisschen ungünstig, ne? Weil das ein brandheißes Thema ist und du dann eben,
ich meine, da waren jetzt Leute von der Future Zone, von Spiegel Online, von Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung, Funke Mediengruppe, Heise
ähm der Reik Anders war da, ähm der Youtuber, den wir ähm bei der LNP zweihundert zu Gast hatten. Ähm.
Und Thomas Rudel von Netzpolitik Org und und und. Also eine größere Gruppe von ich würde sagen.
Fast alle in diesem Themenbereich, in irgendeiner Form einflussreichen.
Der Meinungsführenden ähm Veröffentlichung.
In deutscher Sprache waren da, einige natürlich nicht, ja? Oder teilweise hast du dann halt von sowas wie Süddeutsche Zeitungen, da ist dann ein Journalist, die haben natürlich mehrere, die in diesem Bereich ähm.
Meinungsführend sind. Letztes Jahr war der Tim auf dieser Reise.
Er ist dieses Jahr nicht dabei gewesen wegen der Subscribe. So war ich dann dieses Mal da und da gab es auch letztes Jahr hat der Tim es geschafft vor Ort eine Sendung zu machen zusammen mit dem Holger Bleich und dem Thomas Rudel,
mit denen er dort war. Die haben.
So ein bisschen über dieses Setting Pressereise da auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen. Deswegen kürze ich das jetzt mal.
Ein bisschen ab. Wir waren also dort haben uns.
Größtenteils in Hintergrundgesprächen eben dort informieren lassen. Es war also man fragt sich natürlich.
Ich weniger als die äh Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die ja auch ein Rechtfertigungs.
Problem haben, ne? Wenn die zwei Tage nicht in der Redaktion sind
und da von einem Termin in den anderen gehen und der der Fahrplan war echt voll. Dann haben die in der Zeit kein Output oder können ihre Redaktion nicht leiten oder, oder, oder. Die müssen das natürlich irgendwie auch
dein Zuhause erklären, wo sie die zwei Tage waren. Und die haben natürlich echt ein Problem,
Wenn sie sagen, jo, ich habe hier gerade eine Stunde mit Julia Reder geredet und eine Stunde mit Axel Voss. Und das Thema ist gerade einfach mal glühend heiß und sie können aus dieser Zeit nichts mitnehmen, ne. Das ist
In dieser Situation anstrengend. In anderen Situationen oder in anderen Gesprächen war das eher tolerabel, ja? Also wir haben über die.
Ähm IT-Sicherheitsstrategie der Europäischen Union gesprochen, was ja mein hauptberufliches Thema ist, ähm IT-Sicherheit. Das war interessant und ich verfolge ja auch die.
Regulierungsbemühungen in dem Bereich sowohl in Deutschland als auch in der EU mit Interesse und das war.
Gut zu sehen. Ähm.
Aber ich mein das eine Thema, was halt da die große Rolle gespielt hat, war halt die EU. Äh die äh EU-Erheberrechtsreform.
Und.
Ja und das war tatsächlich dieses Gespräch mit Axel Voss war sehr spannend von mir erwartet worden, weil.
Sicher die Frage stellt und das ist auch glaube ich in der Öffentlichkeit immer noch ein eines der großen Rätsel.
Und ich habe das mal in einem Tweet so gefasst, so wollen die eigentlich uns verarschen oder ihre Wähler? Oder.
Ganz krasse Sache, auf die ich echt nicht gekommen wäre, wollen die uns gar nicht verarschen, sondern sind die tatsächlich so.
Kompetenz, arm, wie es den Eindruck.
Also ich ich glaube man muss
Es ist ein großer Fehler von Axel Voss auf äh ähm das gesamte Europaparlament zu schließen. Der Mensch ist ähm
Für mich wie im Gefäß, wer auch immer von der, von der Lobbyseite mit
den richtigen Wirtschaftsargumenten zu ihm hinkommt, äh kann da Dinge äh reinspulen und er wird sie wieder abspulen in der nächsten Trilog Verhandlung. Ähm äh und und
Er ist auch schon damals bei der Datenschutzgrundverordnung nicht aufgefallen durch sonderlichen Sachverstand äh und und
Kenntnis von dem, was er da eigentlich zu entscheiden hat, sondern eher so über die Sommerpause. Ah, ich habe jetzt ein Buch über äh Maschine Learning gelesen. Wir müssen das alles nochmal neu verhandeln. Ähm
also da da sind durchaus
Das ist so, wie er operiert. Deswegen ist er gewissen Weiten sehr genehm. Ähm aber er ist, glaube ich, nicht derjenige, der wirklich die Entscheidungen trifft.
Das hast du jetzt gesagt, ich würde also.
Wie Barbara Wimmer, die für die Future Zone dort war, hat auch ein äh Artikel über ihre Pressereise dort äh geschrieben, ähm.
Wo sie also schreibt. Dennoch nahmen sich wenige Tage vor der wichtigen Abstimmung über die Uwe Rechtsrichtlinie.
In Brüssel beide Zeit, um ihre Position mit den führenden Digitaljournalisten zu erörtern.
Oft Record versteht sich. Zu viele Statements seien aus dem Kontext gegriffen worden, erklärte der CDU-Politiker im Anschluss des Gesprächs auf die Frage, ob man einzelne Tita
Zitate
freigeben lassen könnte, um als Journalist seinen Auftrag zu erfüllen und die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren. Nein, man du klingst, du der klingt diese Verbitterung raus, ja, dass die Journalisten darüber nicht berichten durften. Ähm.
Es gibt allerdings ja auch einige.
Öffentliche Interviews mit Axel Voss. Ähm spezifisch ist da genannt einmal eines, was auf dem.
Magazin weiß veröffentlicht wurde, also wie äh VICE, ähm wo man einen sehr guten Eindruck bekommt.
Mit ähm einigen wirklichen äh Money Q und ähm es gab auch von.
Puls glaube ich heißt das äh YouTube-Magazin einen Beitrag, wo.
So jemand quasi diese diese Art Kreuzinterview, ne? Also Frage, Antwort von Julia Reder, Antwort von Axel Voss und der zeichnet sich sehr schnell ein.
Bild bei dem man erkennt, dass die Julia Räder ähm sehr sachkompetent in diesem Thema drin ist.
Die ist in der Lage, die Bedeutung jedes einzelnen Artikels zu referieren, die kennt auch jeden einzelnen Artikel, die so die macht diese Arbeit halt enorm kompetent.
Kennen wir ja auch nicht anders. Wir haben sie mehrmals in der Sendung gehabt, wir haben das Thema ja mit ihr hier auch hergeführt und jetzt gibt es ähm einen anderen Ansatz, den man natürlich auch würdigen muss und das ist ähm.
Vielleicht ist da jemand nicht kompetent in dem Thema, was ihm da aufs Auge gedrückt wurde. Stellt man sich natürlich die Frage, warum hat das überhaupt angenommen? Kann ja irgendwie.
Ähm was weiß ich, warum, ja?
Was allerdings in meinen Augen nicht zu verzeihen ist, ist sich dann dieser.
Kompetenzanforderung quasi zu verweigern. Ich finde das nicht schlimm, wenn ähm ein Politiker so ein Parlament, ne, hat ähm mehrere hundert Abgeordnete.
Ganz klar, dass die nicht in allen Bereichen die das Leben in der Europäischen Union für sie bereithält.
Kompetent sein können und.
Wenn du dann eben in dem einen Ausschuss bist und dann ist auf einmal Urheberrechtsreform und der Axel Voss ist ja auch nachgerückt, ja? Ähm der war ja ursprünglich nicht der Berichterstatter dafür, sondern hat dann äh das Thema übernommen von einer anderen Bericht.
Theresa Kommodini aus Malta
war wirklich gut und hält Berti, hätte die den Job erhalten, hätten wir heute ein viel viel besseres Gesetz. Die musste nur leider zurück ins Maltesische Parlament und hat deswegen
diese Reform abgeben müssen, weil sie auch ihr Mandat im Europaparlament abgegeben hat.
So und jetzt bist du da als ähm ähm nicht Experte mit einem Thema betraut
dass die gesamte europäische Union betreffen wird
Und jetzt hast du ja im Prinzip und das so ist ja auch unser gesamter politischer Prozess in Deutschland. Viele Demokratien dieser Erde sind genau so aufgebaut, dass sie sagen, natürlich können wir nicht garantieren, dass unsere.
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter im Parlament, die Kompetenz mitbringen. Für jedes Thema, über das sie da entscheiden müssen. Deswegen segnen wir sie mit ähm.
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, die haben Geld, ähm um die haben Büro, die können sich Wahlkreisbüros unterhalten, die können sich
die haben Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter bei sich im im Parlament sitzen und dann können die sich die Kompetenz und den Sachverstand schlimmstenfalls
einkaufen und das ist auch in Ordnung, ja? Das ist völlig okay, das ist wichtig, das sicherzustellen, ne? Und ähm insbesondere,
Kernkompetenz eines äh eines Parlamentariers ist erstmal äh ewig freundlich zu sein und gut auf einer Bühne zu wirken, ja?
Und natürlich gibt es dann äh ne, kauft man sich dann weitere Leute hinzu, die dann entsprechende inhaltliche Kompetenzen mit dazu bringen, ja oder ergänzen oder sonst was, völlig in Ordnung.
Schlimm ist, wenn man das nicht tut. Schlimm ist.
Wenn man sich hinstellt und sagt, ich bin kein Experte für dieses Thema und meine Aufgabe ist ja hier nur.
Die unterschiedlichen Interessen quasi zu moderieren,
Was ja auch die Aufgabe eines Berichterstatters ist, ähm wenn man sich den Film dem Wogrecy im Rausch der Daten anschaut, ne, da sieht man dann den Jane Philipp Albrecht, ähm der ja auch bei uns ähm in
der zweihundertsechsundfünfzig zu Gast war, gerade dann aus dem EU-Parlament mit der ähm GDPA äh
im Gepäck zurückkam und jetzt den Ministerposten in Schleswig-Holstein gegangen ist und den Ralph Bendrath, seinen ähm,
Wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter glaube ich war die Position oder? War das wissenschaftlicher.
Er war auf jeden Fall Mitarbeiter von Verladenreich. Jetzt ist er.
Kompetenter Mitarbeiter, ja.
Und die beiden haben dann zusammen dieses Thema aufgearbeitet und du siehst, dass der Jan Philipp Albrecht ähm das mit Kompetenz, Sachverstand und Ambition.
Angegangen ist dieses Thema. Ja und ich erwarte nichts anderes als dass sich seriöse Vertreter habe und die eine Ambition haben hier ihrer Verantwortung gerecht zu.
Ein ein großer Unterschied zwischen zwischen äh Jan Philipp Alrecht Ralf und äh Axel Voss ist vor allem auch das Jan und Ralf sich der Tragweite der Entscheidung bewusst waren,
dass das sehr
schwer auch auf ihren Schultern gelastet hat. Ähm wie wichtig diese diese Reform ist als Weichenstellung für
eine halbe Milliarde Menschen, wenn nicht sogar die ganze Welt und ich meine, die haben's geschafft, die ganze Welt kopiert heute, die Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Und äh.
Und den den Eindruck hast du bei bei Axel Voss.
Nein, weil er halt eben wirklich nur dieses klein klein moderierende Interessensgruppen, die mir nahe stehen und nicht okay, was ist die Konsequenz dieser Reform als Ganzes? Was ist überhaupt das Urheberrecht, was wir wollen? Ähm.
Und mit dem, du hast jetzt gerade du sagst, die mir nahe stehen, ähm da muss man natürlich was anderes, die er wahrnimmt.
Ja? Und das ist ja das Problem. Natürlich nimmt er ähm.
Die unabhängigen Urheberinnen und Urheber nicht war, weil sie nicht dorthin kommen können.
Und äh es ist ja auch im Text sogar sichtlich, du hast Ausnahmen äh von Artikel dreizehn, von der Pflichten Uploadfilter zu machen, genau für die Firmen und
Plattformen, die sie's leisten konnten, Lobbyisten zu Axel Forst zu schick,
Ja, deswegen sind irgendwie äh ist eBay ausgenommen zum Beispiel, weil die es geschafft haben, dort vorstellig zu werden. Und,
dass es halt eben nicht vom Thema her gedacht und und zu Ende gedacht, sondern halt einfach nur aha, hier kommt noch was rein. Hier kommt auch was rein, okay, da können wir uns Arbeit ersparen, wenn wir das jetzt schon aufnehmen. Und ähm das hörst du auch
auch wieder ein Argument von was sehr gut funktioniert hat im Parlament. Der Text ist auch so unheimlich schlecht geschrieben,
Ja, also es ist wirklich viel nicht genau definiert, was jetzt wirklich gemeint ist damit und zum Beispiel welche Plattformen direkt jetzt unter
die Pflicht von Upload-Filtern fallen, ist eine Case bei Käseregelung
Das heißt, du hast vor dieser groben Parameter und die müssen alle verhältnismäßig sein. Aber am Ende sagt, gibt der Text hier überhaupt keinen Auffluss drüber? Ob du jetzt filtern musst oder nicht
Da wird am Ende auch wieder ein Gericht entscheiden. Und wenn du glaubst, du fallst nicht runter, irgendeine Verwertungsgesellschaft wird sich finden in Europa, die dich klagt,
und dann musst du so oder so mal irgendwie äh jahrelang vor Gericht prozessieren als kleines Startup. Das ist ihnen,
zwar gesagt worden, aber da war halt auch keine Konkretisierung machbar und äh dass das das ist handwerklich auch alles schlecht gemacht.
Ähm Barbara Wimmer schreibt in ihrem Artikel oft genug, war ihm vorgeworfen worden, das Internet nicht zu verstehen. Dieser Eindruck bestätigte sich bei unserem Gespräch ohne auf die Inhalte
näher eingehen zu dürfen. Ähm darauf bezugnehmend ähm.
Dann wäre die nächste Kompetenz, die ich bei einem Politiker erwartet hätte.
Gewesen, sich in einem solchen Gespräch. Also ich habe ja jetzt gerade mir sehr viel Mühe gegeben zu argumentieren, dass,
Ein Axel Voss natürlich das das es okay ist, wenn Axel Voss nicht der führende Experte für Urheberrecht ist.
Und es vielleicht sogar okay ist, wenn er es nicht wird. Es wäre nur schön gewesen, wenn er jemanden im Team gehabt hätte. Und wenn er noch nicht mal jemanden im Team hat.
Dann hätte ich eine Kompetenz erwartet und das wäre die Kompetenz immer noch eine gute Figur zu machen.
Eine gute Figur heißt paar schöne kluge Sprüche, sich mal ein paar Talking Points geben zu lassen und.
Zum Beispiel ähm zu keinem Zeitpunkt den Eindruck zu vermitteln.
Nicht klüger zu sein als die Frage, die einem gestellt wird.
Und das ist hier auch nicht gelungen und das hat mich enorm.
Schockiert. Und das war nicht nur ich, der nach diesem Gespräch schockiert war. Weil ich.
Ernsthaft, ich stelle persönlich den Anspruch, ich kenne ich spreche das hier in der Sendung aus, häufig genug. Natürlich hat dieses System Parlament und so weiter seine Limitationen. Aber.
Wenn wir Abgeordnete haben, die nicht mit dem Ziel da dran gehen, dass sie.
Ihrer Verantwortung bewusst sich bewusst sind. Dass sie sagen, ich bin ich will hier das Beste Gesetz schaffen
Was möglich ist. Ich habe hier eine Ambition, ich möchte die Expertise aufbauen und ich möchte stolz als der seriöse Vertreter und beste Experte aus dieser Nummer rausgehen. Wenn du diesen Anspruch noch nicht mal an dich selber hast.
Dann weiß ich nicht, warum du da sitzt. Und das ist wirklich.
Das war wirklich schockierend. Der er war da ohne ohne jemanden, der vielleicht im Hintergrund mal kurz am am Ärmelchen, Zipfel, am Ärmelzipfel mal.
Zuppeln konnte und sagen konnte, ey. Ähm hier, ich, ich kann die Frage beantworten. Hatten übrigens alle anderen, ja? Wenn wir da ähm mit keine Ahnung, hohen hochrangigen Mitarbeitern äh der Kommission.
Sprechen, die hatten ihren äh ihre kluge Mitarbeiterin dabei.
Wo er dann irgendwann sagte, was wenn die Frage dann über deine Kompetenz als Grüß August hinausgeht,
Dann sagst du halt mit dem Aspekt hat sich meine Mitarbeiterin XY am meisten auseinandergesetzt, die kann ihnen das jetzt mal schnell erklären.
Weil die das besser weiß als ich,
Das wird dir ja nicht übel genommen, sondern das wird ja honoriert, wenn du wenn du äh erkennst, wer die richtige Person ist. Das ist Führungs
Kompetenz, Führungsqualität und wie wird jetzt diese einen Tag später stattgefunden? Einen Tag später in Berlin. Diese ähm.
Äh diese äh Pressekonferenz dann da zitiert, wo dann äh die Leute gefragt wurden, wer sie denn beraten hätte und du hast einen Helga Trüpel, die sagt, ihr Gesangslehrer.
Ah, da muss man vielleicht kurz einordnen, du sprichst von der Pressekonferenz, die am Donnerstag in Berlin stattgefunden hat, anläs
Licht des Blackouts der Wikipedia, über den wir all wir auch noch sprechen werden. Es ist so viel passiert. Und da waren Vossräder, Timo Wölken und ich glaube Helga Trüppel,
an die erinnere ich mich.
Helga Trüppel ist irgendwie.
Abgeordnete im Europaparlament und ist Befürworterin dieser Reform inklusiver Artikel dreizehn Upload-Filter.
Ja. Na ja. Also was mich um zum Schluss zu kommen. Ich kann leider nicht mehr erzählen. Es gibt dieses Weiß-Interview, es gibt dieses Pulsvideo, das was ich erlebt habe, war.
Ähnlich, ja? Es hat mir die Gewissheit gegeben, dass dieses äh Weiß-Interview nicht bösartig
Zusammengefasst wurde, es hat mir die Gewissheit gegeben, dass dieses Pulsvideo nicht ähm irgendwie tendenziös geschnitten wurde und es hat mir die hat mir den Schlaf geraubt
weil.
Jetzt haben wir diese Situation, dass eben zumindest in Deutschland ein Großteil der Leute jetzt da drauf schaut. Und ähm junge Leute, ja, wenn wir bei den Demonstrationen.
In Berlin. Da waren viele Menschen, wo ich nicht glaube, dass sie schon oft wählen waren. Ja? Ich kenne die Grenzen nicht ab wann man wählen darf und so weiter. Aber vom Alter her konnten die jetzt noch nicht oft gewählt haben.
Und jetzt gucken die auf so einen Gesetzgebungsprozess, ja? Und sehen da.
Ähm so eine Reihe an Hütchenspielertricks Inkompetenz, Lügen, ja, wir wurden ja mehrmals angelogen, als Bots verunglimpft, ja? Ähm.
An wen wenden, wohin wenden die sich jetzt? Ja und.
Da komme ich dann auch tatsächlich zu sag mal vorsichtig rüber zum Thema ähm Demonstration.
Denn diese dieses Thema Zensur.
Zensurfilter, ja? Was ja eben wiederkehrend ist. Das hat natürlich jetzt auch direkt dazu geführt, dass äh sich hier die die AfD ähm eine,
ebenso durch äh Sachkompetenz selten aufgefallene Partei
volles Fund da dranhängt, ja? Und jetzt sagt, ja, hier die Mächtigen wollen äh das Volk kontrollieren, das Internet äh hat uns äh befreit und jetzt ähm fürchten die mächtigen sich und müssen uns zensieren. Das ist.
Dann am Ende ähnlich unterkomplex wie ähm die Argumentation, die wir von den Verfechtern von Artikel dreizehn hören.
Und das insgesamt das ist etwas, was mir was mir echt Sorgen macht. Ja, ich möchte, dass.
In der Politik die Komplexität des Sachverhaltes gewürdigt wird. Möchte das die Leute erkennen, dass es keine einfachen Lösungen gibt, erst recht nicht, wenn alle Sachverständigen sagen, das geht so nicht.
Und.
Deswegen bin ich da wirklich, ich meine, ich hätte lachen können, ich hätte sauer sein können, aber auf mich war's einfach nur, ich war beklommen.
Ich war beklommen.
Ja ähm das Wichtige ist an solchen Momenten mit dieser Energie was zu tun und dieses Beklommensein,
zu kanalisieren in okay und jetzt gehe ich auf die Straße und jetzt äh spreche ich mit anderen Leuten drüber. Also ähm
eine, das haben wir eben der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt, oder? Die ähm die Strategie der Gegenseite ist gerade uns die Hoffnung zu nehmen
Und das so darzustellen, dass es schon entschieden ist und dass wir jetzt nur noch abnicken müssen und das war's. Das ist es nicht und ich glaube, solange da Leute noch irgendwie Zeichen setzen und wir hatten die Woche wirklich viele starke Zeichen. Äh gibt's da auch noch eine eine reale Chance?
Aber ähm ja kommen wir mal zu den Dimos, oder? Ich glaube, das ist der große Elefant im Raum. Es waren.
Europaweit sind inzwischen schon die Zahlen drinnen und es schwankt so irgendwo äh zwischen hundertfünfzig und zweihunderttausend äh,
Teilnehmer in ganz Europa
Sprich, es ist wirklich in in vielen, vielen Städten demonstriert worden. Der größte Teil war in Deutschland und glaube ich alleine in Deutschland um die hunderttausend Menschen, die auf die Straße gegangen sind.
Und ähm ja
Das ist genau die Art von dezentraler Protestbewegung, die überschwappt, wo das Internet mal wirklich auf die Straße geht, die die wir uns immer gewünscht haben. Ähm und äh ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber mich hat's ganz stark an Akte erinnert.
Also in Wien waren wir ähm gezählt, wirklich aha genau gezählt viertausend Leute äh wobei über die Einkaufsstraße auch immer wieder Leute dazugekommen sind. Also die Demo ist angewachsen. Ähm
wir waren sehr bunt, also es war vom Altersdurchschnitt her total quer gemischt, von ähm sechzig, siebzigjährigen bis zu,
Zwölfjährigen, Achtjährigen.
Die aber auch wirklich mit die Parolen gesungen haben, eigene Schilder da hatten ähm und und äh die da definitiv auch äh mit mit ihrer eigenen Motivation waren und und ihren eigenen äh Sorgen bei der ganzen Geschichte,
Wir hatten auch einen Redner bei der Demo, der dreizehn war,
und sehr äh gut gesprochen hat, auch von sich sagt, er will Politiker werden, ich unterstütze ihn dabei.
Hieß der Philipp Anto, Amt.
Muss ich nachschauen, ich habe eine,
aber auf jeden Fall da ist äh ja viele gute Fotos, die wir verlinken werden und viele, viele tolle Menschen, die das möglich gemacht haben. Ähm und es war auch die komplette Opposition mit ihren Parteien vor Ort
und alle haben sie nochmal ausgesprochen dagegen zu stimmen, ähm wie die Regierungsparteien in Österreich abstimmen werden. Wird spannend.
Und ich hoffe, dass wir da vielleicht auch irgendwie noch ein paar Stimmen bekommen könnten. Wir arbeiten zumindest dran. Ähm
aber ja ich glaub wir hatten in äh zwei anderen österreichischen Städten auch noch äh parallelaktionen in Innsbruck und ich glaube in Linz, wenn ich mich nicht irre, ähm
Also es ist auf jeden Fall äh Bewegung da und äh in Deutschland was natürlich,
weit, weitaus größer, noch. Insgesamt muss man sagen, diese Demonstrationen sind größer als bei Akta,
Das ist schon auch so ein spannendes Zeichen. Es gibt wieder diese polnisch-deutsche Brücke.
Ich glaube, dass da das Epizentrum dieser ganzen Protestbewegung ist, zumindest die, die sich äh auf der Straße manifestieren. Ähm aber erzähl du mal, wie es in Berlin so war.
Also ich kann jetzt nur aus Berlin berichten, weil nur da war ich vor Ort. Ähm.
Es ging los am Potsdamer Platz das ist ein relativ großer Platz und da waren irgendwann so viele Leute, dass sie immer wieder
sie konnten nicht mehr auf dem Platz stehen, sondern die mussten dann irgendwann die Straße sperren. Und das war schon vor Beginn der Veranstaltung der Fall, die um vierzehn Uhr beginnen sollte
und da gab's dann halt so erste Probleme quasi mit der Polizei zur Polizei, sagte, passen sie bitte auf, dass diese Leute hier auf die Straße gehen und wir dann quasi sagten so, na ja
Die sind halt so viele, können sie das nicht irgendwie äh können sie Straße nicht sperren? Die so, ja nee, erst ab vierzehn Uhr fängt die Veranstaltung losgeht
Gas, also es war wirklich sehr, sehr stark.
Sehr, sehr viel mehr als äh eingeplant war von Seiten der Polizei und von Seiten der der Veranstalter. Ähm wir sind dann die.
Eine relativ kurze Demorte gegangen, also relativ kurz meine ich, weil's also.
Hätte jetzt auch noch durch die ganze Stadt gehen können. Man hätte auch vom Potsdamer Platz es noch zum CDU ähm Versteck äh schaffen können, wo die sich äh immer wo die sich verstecken drin ähm.
In dem Glashaus. Ähm das hätte man machen können, das ging, dagegen war die Route nicht lang. Deswegen meine ich, die war jetzt relativ kurz und ähm.
Es war, ich habe irgendwann einmal äh von der von ganz vorne ähm.
Angehalten hab ich ein paar Leute getroffen, mit denen ich dann gequatscht habe.
Es waren ungefähr so fünfunddreißig Minuten bis diese gesamte Demonstration an mir vorbei gelaufen war. Und diese und das war auf der.
Äh ich kenne die, also jetzt fällt mir der Straßenname nicht ein.
Also quasi ähm in der Nähe des Willy-Brandt-Hauses, Wilhelmstraße heißt die. Ähm,
Das ist eine relativ breite Straße, wo die Autos schnell fahren und die komplette Straße war voll, die kompletten
Gehsteige und das dauerte dann irgendwie. Also es war ja wirklich eng, ne? Es waren ich habe mich dann auch zurückfallen lassen, weil ich ein Fahrrad dabei hatte und ähm.
Konnte ich hab ich konnte mich einfach nicht bewegen, ich konnte das nirgendwo anschließen, ich konnte aber auch in dieser Menge nicht irgendwie mich nennenswert bewegen und deswegen bin ich dann irgendwann einfach mal stehen geblieben. Es war wirklich, wirklich.
Voll und es ist lange her.
Dass wir in Berlin im Netzpolitischen Bereich so viele Leute hatten. Ähm ich habe mit Markus Beckedal kurz geredet und.
Es war wohl ein Vielfaches oder also nicht ein Vielfaches, aber auf jeden Fall mehr als ähm
Jede Freiheit statt Angst, die Modis hier in Berlin gab und die Freiheit statt Angst dem muss man große wichtige Demonstrationen, ja, die ähm zu den
Zeiten nacht eben den Terrorgesetzgebung vorratsanspeicherung und so weiter über mehrere Jahre in Berlin stattgefunden haben.
Wie immer wichtige Zeichen gesetzt haben dann irgendwann wieder kleiner wurden und das war immer so mein Eindruck, dass das so quasi der der Messwert ähm netzpolitische Demonstration in Berlin ist und das war eben.
Sehr viel mehr.
Schätzungen liegen irgendwo zwischen dreißig und vierzigtausend Leuten. Ich würde so fünfunddreißig würde ich auch schätzen. Leute waren wirklich unermüdlich mit ihren Sprechkurven? Chören, Kuren, Kurs.
Das ging also insbesondere das mit den Bots hat die Leute echt angepisst. Also es war glaube ich der häufigste Sprechchor. Wir sind keine Bots. Wir sind keine Bots. Ähm.
Es gab eine ganze Reihe an echt coolen Plakaten.
Also ähm immer schön an diesen also an vielen Internetmames angedockt, ja? Mein Lieblingsplakat war, glaube ich, ähm.
Wenn wenn Annegret die Uploadfilter stopft, äh stoppt, dann äh darf sie auch im Sitzen pinkeln.
Also da war wirklich gut was dabei, ja? Da war wirklich gut was dabei. Und ähm ja ich hatte ich hatte das ja in der Sendung mit mit Markus auch schon mal so,
angedeutet, dass es ich persönlich, das einfach nur mein persönliches.
Ästhetisches Empfinden. Ich komme mit diesen Sprechkönnen nicht so.
Zurecht. Ähm insbesondere wenn die ähm so ein Hin und Her haben, ja? Also wenn jemand auf der äh Bühne steht und schreit
den ersten Teil und dann die Masse ruft den anderen Teil, ja? Das weckt bei mir einfach so ein bisschen unangenehme.
Ähm ähm Erinnerung, ja, das ist einfach nicht mein Ding. Das soll nicht heißen, dass es niemand machen soll. Ich fühle mich da nur nicht so wohl drin. Ähm das war aber die ganze Zeit auch sehr laut und immer.
Nicht klar zu kriegen und ähm es gab dann wirklich ein ein harten Kern und die Leute waren auch irgendwann als die Demo dann am an der Reichstagswiese entlang ging. Da waren auch viele schon echt
heiser und unermüdlich haben sie geschrien, ne? Wir sind keine Bots und keine Zensur und so weiter. Ähm.
Das war wirklich ähm mal wieder wirklich toll, so eine so eine Energie zu sehen. Ähm ich bin ein paar Mal auch von.
Hörerinnen und Hörern ertappt worden, die sich dann freundlich angesprochen haben, hat mich auch sehr gefreut. Ähm.
Ich hoffe, dass ich da nicht irgendwann mal äh euch den den Eindruck gegeben habe, dass ihr stören würdet oder so. Ich habe mich eh über jede jeden einzelnen und jede einzelne von euch sehr gefreut, dass ihr da wart.
Und ähm hoffe, dass ihr da auch eine so schöne.
So schöne Zeit hattet, durch irgendwie positiv in Erinnerung bleibt.
Die Demo endete dann am Brandenburger Tor.
Wo schon so ein ähm LKW quasi vorher schon bereit stand.
Um da die Abschlusskundgebung zu machen und da gab es dann eine ganze Reihe an Redebeiträgen. Der erste war von Julia. Julia Reder ähm.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, ein ein Redebeitrag war auch für mich eingeplant. Also ich war eingeplant für einen Redebeitrag als Vertreter des Chaos-Computerclubs, der ähm maßgeblich,
Maßgeblich ist hier der falsche Begriff, der auch bei dem Aufbau der Infrastruktur dieser Demonstration äh beteiligt war. Das waren schöne Zeit im,
cooles Engagement von Leuten im Chaoscomputerclub Berlin und vielen anderen wie dem Bündnis Safety Internet digitale Freiheit und ähm so weiter die da mitgemacht haben alles wirklich richtig.
Richtig geil.
Und dann kamen halt diese Redebeiträge und es war so ein bisschen eingeplant, dass mein Redebeitrag der letzte sein würde. Und ich habe dann irgendwie mit äh habe dann gesehen, wie viele Redebeiträge es gibt und habe dann schon relativ schnell, also nach Julias Beitrag eh gedacht so
jetzt gibt's eigentlich nichts mehr zu sagen, weil jetzt ist ja alles gesagt. Ja, Julia hat irgendwie ihre
Werden acht bis zwölf Minuten gewesen sein und es gibt einfach niemanden, der also es gab danach nichts mehr, was man.
Leider nicht das erste Reden, das ist so.
Hätte es auch jeden anderen als erstes reden lassen können, weil die natürlich alle das Gleiche gesagt haben und ähm ich habe dann.
Also muss ich auch dazu sagen, weil ich eben mit diesen vor Mengen Forderungen, Schreien und Zwischenrufe und anfeuern und so, weil mir persönlich das nicht so angenehm ist.
Hatte ich schon von vornherein immer nicht wirklich
Lust das zu machen, ja? Gesagt, okay, ich mach's, weil muss sein, so Chaos-Computerclub da mitgemacht, Geld macht unsere Leute haben da Engagement gezeigt und ähm.
Ich meine, der Chaos-Computerclub setzt sich ja seit langem für dieses Thema ein, auch bevor es irgendwie jetzt in den letzten Wochen dann auch ähm in die Öffentlichkeit übergesprungen ist, ähm sollte natürlich als Mitglied des Demobündnisses jetzt auch die Stimme des CC,
fehlen. Aber das war einfach irgendwann so eisern, ja? Dass selbst ich ja als eine
derjenigen, die dieses Thema seit langer Zeit verfolgen, die da voll dahinter sind, die für die es natürlich ein ganz, ganz
tolle Situation ist, wenn so viele Menschen da demonstrieren, selbst ich irgendwann mit kalten Füßen am Brandenburger Tor stand und sagte so, wie viele Redebeiträge denn noch? Ja und ähm es war und war kein Ende zu sehen und dann habe ich irgendwann ähm bin ich dann
da nochmal hingegangen und habe gesagt, ey komm, ich sage das jetzt ab, ne? Ich möchte, ich möchte das nicht machen.
Eh nichts mehr dem hinzuzufügen was hier gesagt wurde. Es waren viele gute Redebeiträge, die haben auch alle Spaß gehabt, die Leute haben Spaß da dran gehabt
Und ähm da brauche ich jetzt nicht auch nochmal hinzugehen. Es wurde alles gesagt, nur noch nicht von allen und ähm das das war dann irgendwie auch irgendwann.
Nicht mehr nötig. Dann bin ich ähm.
Gerade da zurückgekommen, hatte gerade abgesagt, habe ich Markus Becke da getroffen. Ich sage und äh wie sieht's aus, ne? Markus, ah ja, hier unten, da sage ich, ich habe gerade meinen Redebeitrag abgesagt,
Markus so. Jo, ich auch. Also ist eigentlich ganz interessant, ja, dass äh ähm.
Also es waren viele, es waren neue Leute da, ja? Junge Menschen, die da auch insbesondere zu Beginn,
hier ähm jetzt fällt mir der Nachname gerade nicht ein Viktor von digitale Freiheit, weil zweiter dritter Redner, der auch ganz
mit Verf dabei war und auch ein bisschen das Fenster ein bisschen weiter geöffnet hat als dieses Zensurthema. Ja, das ist jetzt äh
ich meine ja was man auf einer Demo ruft muss kurz und prägnant sein.
Aber ähm egal wie,
Also Zensur ist halt ein ein großes Wort. Und da habe ich mich dann schon über ähm die Redebeiträge gefreut, die da ein bisschen differenzierter waren.
Ähm.
Und auch mal ähm das eine weitere, also das Fenster ein bisschen weiter geöffnet haben. Was da eigentlich schiefgeht, ja? Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie nur um Artikel dreizehn geht, sondern eben auch darum, äh.
Sich in Zukunft politisch einzubringen und ich hoffe natürlich
Ähm weshalb ich immer diesen Vergleich zur Freiheit statt Angst ziehe, die Freistaat Angst war für für sehr viele Leute
sodass entscheidende, der, der entscheidende Politisierungsmoment, nämlich dass man da sagt, ey, da gibt's irgendwelche Gesetze, die passen, die taugen mir irgendwie nicht so und jetzt gibt's da mal so eine Demo und jetzt gehe ich da mal hin und wupp, jetzt sind da auf einmal was weiß ich
mehrere äh tausend, mehrere zehntausend Leute, ja. Und.
Oh, interessant, das das interessiert also nicht nur mich das Thema, das ist nicht nur irgendwie so ein Nischending, sondern.
Ne, hier das ist irgendwie, das ist so groß, das könnte Identitätsstiften sein, ja? Und ich hatte, du hattest ganz klar dieses dieses Knistern in der ähm.
In der Luft, dass solche Momente halt mit sich bringen. Und das war äh.
Großartig. Muss ich, also es war, war wirklich spitze und jetzt äh ist natürlich immer schwierig, da Leuten zu zu danken, weil das,
unglaublich viele Leute sich da unglaublich eingebracht haben von coole, transparente machen, coole Aktionen machen, Karren anmieten, ähm am Ende den ganzen Kram aufbauen, aber,
Eine Person will ich dann doch nochmal äh persönlich rauspicken und das war der äh Brunogramm. Bruno Gert Gramm
Der ähm ich weiß gar nicht mehr früher in Berlin ein äh Zentrales Gesicht in der Piratenpartei war. Ähm ich weiß nicht.
Inwiefern der überhaupt jetzt noch parteimäßig da eingebunden ist oder nicht. Ja, sehr, sehr bemüht und sehr erfolgreich dieses Bündnis halt äh breit zu gestalten.
Dass gegen die Vereinnahmung von Parteien zu verteidigen
Du hattest ja gerade gesagt, in Wien gab es äh irgendwie viele Parteiauftritte. In Berlin war das quasi erklärter Wunsch der Organisatorinnen und Organisatoren beim Thema zu bleiben
Ist natürlich schwierig, wenn du dann als erstes Julia Reder als äh Rednerin hast, dann fangen natürlich die anderen Parteien ähm an zu quengeln und natürlich war auch die eine oder andere Fahne einer Partei dort vertreten
Aber es war klar, das war eine eine Gras-Roods
äh Demonstrationen. Wer hat der Bruno äh wirklich? Will nicht wissen, wie viele Stunden der in dieser Sache versenkt hat und noch eine coole Band auf die Bühne geschafft. Und hier noch und da noch und immer mit einer mit einer äh wirklich.
Mit so einer Sonnenschein ähm.
Stimmung und Freundlichkeit, ähm die man so im Grufti gar nicht immer zutraut, ja. Ähm also das war wirklich, das war wirklich ganz toll und ich hoffe.
Ähm dass alle, die da waren, das auch so empfunden haben und ähm das so so mitnehmen.
Damit komme ich aber auch nochmal zum zu dem anderen Ding, was warum ich eben meine, was mir so Sorgen macht, ist was nehmen die mit, wenn jetzt da die Entscheidung kommt, ja.
Was haben, was haben die? Äh also dieser dieser wirklich dieser Raubbau.
An der Demokratie, ja, der da, der da stattfindet, dass den Menschen den Glauben zu nehmen, das ist das Schlimmste, was du in der Demokratie antun kannst, ist den Menschen den Glauben daran zu nehmen.
Und das haben dieser äh Axel Voss, dieser äh Manfred Weber.
Und einige andere, die sich eben so unqualifiziert in diesem Bereich geäußert haben, die.
Die anderen verunglimpft haben getan. Jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, inwiefern.
Es da vielleicht auch Beiträge auf in Anführungszeichen unserer Seite gab.
Ähm wie gesagt, ich hatte nicht den Eindruck, dass alle Youtuber sich besonders differenziert mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben.
Aber.
Ähm es klingt jetzt so ein bisschen durft. Die Zivilgesellschaft darf das, sich unseriös mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen. Die Politiker dürfen es nicht.
Ja und das ist ein entscheidender Unterschied. Ähm ich meine, ich muss das nicht gut finden. Ähm ich meine für unterkomplexe Äußerungen war ich selten zu erwärmen, aber
Es ist halt einfach ein Unterschied, ob du ein ein Amts oder Mandatträger bist oder eben irgendwer.
Und dies darf sich, also das laste ich deshalb tatsächlich ganz, ganz klar der.
Der Politik an oder diesen Menschen an und selbst wenn.
Deine Gegner alle von YouTube gekauft sind, dann kannst du sie ja erst recht argumentativ ähm
ähm ausstechen. Und das zeigt ja, äh also dieses diese ihr seid alle nur gekauft, ist ja auch ist es einfach die schlechteste Entgegnung, die irgendjemandem einfallen kann.
Ja, wobei im September haben sie damit gewonnen. Ich erinnere mich noch, nachdem wir Juli äh haben wir im Plenum gewonnen, dass das äh Ergebnis von Axel Forss nicht einfach so in den Trilog geschickt wird
Und dann kam als Hauptargument der Gegenseite nur noch dieses, das sind alle Spots. Diese E-Mails sind nicht echt, diese Tweets sind nicht echt. Schau, die sind alle aus den USA.
Und damit haben Sie im September gewonnen. Damals dachte ich, okay, wenn das die einzige
Argumentation jetzt gerade ist, dass man äh halb Seiten in der FAZ lesen kann äh dass da äh ich weiß nicht, Edri mal zweitausendfünfhundert Euro von Google bekommen habe vor vier Jahren. Äh deswegen ist jetzt alles hier von Google finanziert
und jeder Tweet normal äh unabhängig vom eigentlichen Inhalt äh auch nur aufgrund eines
Angenommenen Absenders schon nicht ernst zu nehmen. Da habe ich gelacht, aber das hat dann trotzdem noch für eine Mehrheit gereicht und dann ist ja deutliche Dame im September. Ich glaube, was sich jetzt hier geändert hat, ist, dass ähm.
Das Ergebnis jetzt am Tisch liegt, dass wir die Konsequenzen auch genau durchdeklinieren können. Und die Bedrohung ist um einiges realer geworden.
Und,
du hast es eh vorher schon gesagt, ja, Zivilgesellschaft äh darf auch mal schwammig argumentieren. Ähm wenn ich Vorstellungen für mein Gesundheitssystem habe, dann bin ich in den allermeisten Fällen
kein Experte in diesem hochkomplexen Themenbereichen kann dir das
so argumentieren, dass es aus Polecy auch nur annähernd Sinn ergibt, ja, wie da jetzt welcher Pharmakonzern an welche Krankenkasse und welchen Arzt da steigen wir alle aus. Trotzdem habe ich eine Meinung, äh,
die als Werturteil durchaus in einem politischen Entscheidungsprozess finde ich gehört werden muss. Und
Am Ende musst du halt immer diese Menge an Stimmen vom Botum ab, auch mit Expertenmeinungen gegenüberstellen. Deswegen äh ist es so wichtig bei bei den Zensur.
Vorwurf zeigt ja auch die Gegenseite oft. Das ist keine Zensur, weil das macht ja nicht der Staat. Ähm,
Ja, aber wenn der Staat Gesetze erlässt, die Firmen dazu zwingend zu zensieren, kann man's immer noch Zensur nennen.
Thomas, ganz ehrlich, da muss ich nochmal kurz einhaken. Zensur ist
äh äh etwas, was staatlich passiert. Und was diese Richtlinie verlangt, ist nicht eine Zensur, diese diese Richtlinie verlangt das. Hm, Urheberrechtsverletzungen
Blockiert werden. Da steht nicht, ähm was weiß ich äh Piraten müssen zensiert werden oder so. Das sind einfach, ich finde das gut, wenn dass wir viele Wörter haben.
Um unterschiedliche Dinge zu bezeichnen. Und ich finde.
Darf ich hier.
Ganz kurz, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt an dieser ich weiß ja, dass wir einer Meinung sind. Ja, ich finde es ein wichtiger, wichtiges.
Viel, viel, viel zu unbeachteter.
Dieser Richtlinie ist eben die Stärkung großer Plattform, ja? Und das hätte ich mir, das hätte ich mir viel mehr gewünscht.
Da sind wir uns eher einig, aber nur zu diesem Punkt, ja.
Statement des UN-Sonderberichterstatters für Meinungsfreiheit von vor zwei Wochen in Bezug auf den aktuellen Texte nächste Woche angestimmt wird. Und er verwendet das Wortsänzer sch.
Ja, der ist doch von Google gekauft.
Ja genau,
er schreibt hier Miss Place Conference in Firtoring, Technologies, Tomak Nowans, Distinctionspedre in Copyright Valations and let Ginimit Users of Protected Naturial. Wood Eskalate to Risk of Er and Sensorship.
Also auch er verwendet dieses Wort, wenn er über dieses Gesetz schreibt ähm und ich habe in gewisser Weise auch mehr Angst vor dem privatisierten,
Kontroll und Überwachungsmethoden siehe äh Social Credit Score in in China, als wenn das nur in staatlicher Hand ist. Aber die Debatte führt vielleicht zu weit.
Wir wir kämpfen immer gegen privater, privatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung und so und es sind als wenn den Begriff kriegst du halt nicht auf einer Demo geschrien und so, ne? Und das ist auch, finde ist auch wichtig an so einem breiten Bündnis, dass ähm dass ähm.
Na in, dass einige halt die die komplexe Arbeit machen
ja, sich mit der, mit den Dingen auseinandersetzen, so wie du nach Brüssel fahren oder wie Julia im Parlament sitzen und sich damit auseinandersetzen und andere auf einer Demo einen griffigen Slogan bringen
Ja, das ist so breit muss das sein, ja.
Und das bringt mich auch so zu meinem meinem meiner Hoffnung oder meinem auf.
Aber ganz kurz, meine mein Hauptproblem ist, weißt du.
Man könnte noch sehr viel besser gegenüber so einem Axel-Force aussehen. Ich hab's ja erlebt, ne? Also ähm.
Der Weiher ist tatsächlich hat Schwierigkeiten das Beste, was du eigentlich machen kannst, um ähm.
Um Axel Voss zu diskreditieren, ist ihn reden lassen. Ja? Das, das reicht.
Linus, das ist auch wieder nur mit deiner Brille. Der Mensch hat einen ganz sicheren Listenplatz in NRW und wird auch im nächsten.
Listenplatz vier, ja.
Genau, also das sind äh der, der hat auch seine Basis für die er mit allem, was er sagt, ähm Spitzenmann ist, den schicken wir nach Brüssel. Also das, das muss man alles wieder relativieren.
Aber diese diese Richtlinie wenn wenn es gelingt den Artikel dreizehn.
Abzulehnen oder die ähm die gesamte äh Reform abzulehnen. Ja? Dann ist das nicht wegen Zensur.
Dann ist das, weil die erkannt haben, dass es ein Handwerksschicht nicht schlechtes Gesetz ist, weil sie erkannt haben, dass sie damit nicht
Google und Facebook schwächen werden, dass sie damit nicht,
Für die Urheber mehr Geld rausholen und wenn sie das erkannt haben, dann können auch Leute irgendwann ähm ähm.
Verteidigen, dass sie dagegen gestimmt haben gegen ein handwerklich schlechtes Gesetz. Und ich mein du kannst nicht als seriöser Vertreter
irgendwie gegen die gegen diese Reform stimmen und dann wirst du gefragt, was ist denn hier los? Warum hast du denn dagegen gestimmt? Hast du etwa Künstler,
Möchtest du die, möchtest du die armen Künstler weiter ausnutzen? Findest du Diebstahl gut und du antwortest dann mit ja aber Zensurer. Nein, nein, nein, da musst du halt fundiert antworten,
Ja und das ist halt auch tatsächlich das, wogegen ich mich wende bei diesen.
Bei diesem Axel Voss und was ich eben auch bei auf unserer Seite ungern.
Wahrnehme, ja? Ich toleriere das, ich weiß es muss sein, aber ich.
Das das Schöne finde ich an der Politik ist ja gerade, dass du unterschiedliche Argumente gegenüber unterschiedlichen Leiden verwendest
Und dieses äh Meinungsfreiheitsargument
ist für andere Politiker das, was ich voranstelle und äh bei den eher wirtschaftlichen oder äh Politikern komme ich dann halt mit dem Rechtsstaatlichkeitsargument oder
es gibt ja so viele im Moment, also wir haben äh äh auch äh diese Woche ähm Dienstag kam ein Brief heraus äh von inzwischen sind's über zweihundert Start-ups
Die sagen, wenn Uploadfilter so kommen, dann bricht uns, dass das Genick äh dann dann müssen wir hier irgendwie abwandern, weil äh wir
uns definitiv nicht diesem Haftungsrisiko aussetzen können. Und weil wir die Technik nicht haben, uns davor äh irgendwie zu schützen und darunter sind zum Beispiel so Firmen wie Next.
Die ein Hauptmitbewerber von Google Dogs und Google Drive sind, die einfach sagen, wir können das nicht leisten, was sie hier ins Gesetz schreibt,
da sind einige drunter. Tim hat das auch unterschrieben, äh mit ähm wie heißt das nochmal? Mieterebene, genau
und das heißt das sind wirklich viele dabei und das ist wiederum eigenes Argument oder wenn du
dann vielleicht auch mit dem wissenschaftlichen Statement argumentieren wirst. Auch die Koalition von über zweihundert Wissenschaftlerinnen in dem Bereich, von Intellectural Propedy Law aus Europa, an den führenden wissenschaftlichen Institutionen haben auch jetzt gerade wieder ein Statement rausgebracht. Also du hast immer
die relevanten Stimmen, auf die du dich beziehen kannst, aber wie du das jetzt gerade framst. Äh zwischen einem Lobbygespräch in Brüssel und dem, was du gegenüber Axel Voss sagst,
was auf 'ne Demo geschrien wird sind natürlich Welten, aber genau.
Ja, also ist total richtig, aber das ist, das ist mein ich, also ich äh mir ist ja auch klar, eine Demonstration kann nicht anfangen mit einer langen äh weißt du mit einem, mit irgendeinem langen.
Text oder so, ne? Das muss irgendwie knackig sein und der, wie gesagt, da gab's auch.
Von den Besucherinnen und Besuchern und demonstrierenden und gab es auf jeden Fall ähm ich sage mal mehr Kreativität als von.
Einigen die da lautstark gerufen haben, ja? Und das, wie.
Das Schöne, das Schöne.
Habe ja auch mehrfach den Disclay mal gesagt, so dass ich dieses,
dass ich ein persönliches Problem habe, was äh was diese, was diese Rufrufe angeht, ja? Das ist mir mein, mein Ding so. Das filtere ich da ja auch raus.
Ja, also ist er.
Das Schöne bei solchen Kampagnen, wenn sie wirklich abheben, ist weiß nicht, ob ich das hier im Podcast schon mal gesagt habe, aber es ist das ist mir schon einige Male passiert. Es gibt diesen schönen Moment des Kontrollverlustes. Ähm wenn du an einem, einem,
politischen Thema arbeitest, wo du auf einmal mehr riefst, dann.
Hast du auf einmal Menschen, die du die du nicht kennst, an die du nie gedacht hättest, die an Orten, wo du niemals warst, mit deinem Thema.
Argumentieren und und Dinge tun, die du nie vorhergesagt hättest. Und genau aufgrund dieser Breite hast du dann auf einmal diese Durchschlagskraft
Das war damals bei der ersten Petition gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als irgendwelche Leute in Baden, wo niemand von uns dann gedacht hätte, eher so Kurort mit alten Leuten, von Tür zu Tür gegangen sind oder Unterschriften eingesammelt haben
Ähm und äh sowas hast du an an jeder erfolgreichen Kampagne bei gewissen Punkten genau da sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon seit einigen Wochen drinnen.
Und dadurch hat das eben, du hast vorher einen Satz, also zwei Wörter gesagt, die ich sehr schön fande. Identitätsstiftender Moment.
Punkt würde ich gerne noch herausgreifen. Hier passiert gerade.
Äh etwas sehr Wichtiges im Leben von ganz vielen Menschen. Die haben zum ersten Mal das Gefühl eine Stimme zu haben.
Dass sie ein Thema so weit verstanden haben, dass sie wirklich eine Meinung dazu haben und mit dieser Meinung auch ähm.
Nach außen gehen, verbalisieren, sich in der Gruppe wiederfinden,
und das ist extremes Empowerment, ja? Es passiert unter denkbar dieses Trösten Bedingungen mit
Eine gesamten Medienlandschaft, die ähm dir vorwirft, äh zur ersten Bot zu zahlen und dann bezahlt der Demonstrant zu sein und so weiter und Politikern, die offensichtlich nicht eine Argumente verstehen, die hier nicht mal was zu
Würde Axel Voss irgendwie der Politik glaubhaft lügen? Wieso das das Richtige wäre?
Sehe die Sache vielleicht anders aus, aber es ist so ein starker Konsens unterm großen Teil der Bevölkerung, dass das eben wirklich Identitätsstiftend ist. Und
Ich glaube, der Zensur soll er Moment in Deutschland war ähnlich in die die Akta und Vorratsdatenspeicherung vielleicht in Österreich und die Frage ist immer, was machen wir daraus? Weil wenn wir jetzt zurückblicken, sehen wir, dass
diese Wellen noch wieder abeppen. Und die Leut.
Also ich sage dir, was ich dara.
Ganz kurz noch.
Mein meine meine Hoffnung wäre, genauso diese Breite der Debatte von wir schreien da was vom Wagen oder wir schauen uns wirklich die Gesetze an. Da da sind,
Tausende Dinge
zwischen und wir haben nur dann Erfolg, wenn du irgendwie es schaffst, die zu verbinden in in einer Kampagne, in einer Bewegung, in einer NGO, in einer Community, die sich gegenseitig hilft
und äh wir haben, glaube ich, jetzt gerade wieder so eine Chance, solche Brücken zu bauen und dadurch als Community insgesamt stärker zu werden, unsere Blase
mindestens zu vergrößern, wenn nicht vielleicht doch bissel aus ihr auszubrechen und damals bei Akta haben wir das nicht geschafft. Ich ich
Behaupte, das wird deswegen wahrscheinlich auch einige Sachen verloren haben, die wir hätten gewinnen können. Und jetzt sozusagen unabhängig davon, wie es am Dienstag ausgeht, natürlich aber erst recht, wenn wir gewinnen, geht es darum, ähm.
Da wirklich nachhaltig Kooperationen zu bauen. Und diese Leute einzub,
und sich nicht auf so erstmal irgendwie hinhören, wie wieso die auf einmal auch dagegen sind und wie wir voneinander lernen können. Und im besten Fall entstehen da Freundschaften oder neue
Arbeitsbeziehungen, die uns helfen in.
Der Uploadfilterter Terrorismusverordnung zum Beispiel wird am ersten April im Ausschuss abgestimmt, das wäre so die, die naheliegendste Brücke mit allen Leuten, die jetzt zum ersten Mal politisch aktiv geworden sind, dann zu sagen, okay, und einen brauchen wir noch. Und dann haben wir schon zwei gemeinsame
Themen, wo wir gekämpft haben, seit Seite und Seite und vielleicht wird daraus dann auch mehr, womit wir in Zukunft arbeiten können.
Okay, dann pass auf, dann sage ich nur.
Ne, mir geht's nicht darum, äh ich hoffe, es ist auch nicht so rübergekommen, dass ich irgendjemanden ähm mich lieber nicht hätte, der gegen dieses Gesetz ist. Mir geht's, mir geht's wirklich darum,
in diesem Identitätsstiftenden Moment, was nehmen die mit? Und wenn die jetzt lernen.
Okay, das sind alles irgendwie äh Doofmänner und die sind alle gekauft und die diskreditieren uns. Dann habe ich halt Sorge.
Dass die Menschen sich irgendwelchen anderen Parteien zuwenden.
Die kein Deutsch kompetenter sind, aber einfach nur lauter irgendwelche Vorwürfe erheben. Und genau das Gegenteil ist das, was jetzt notwendig ist.
Was jetzt notwendig ist, ist, dass alle erkennen, okay, hey
Politik, komplexes Thema, müssen wir aufpassen, dass da seriöse Leute sind. Nicht, dass wir nachher hier auch so einen Donald Trump haben, nur weil der gesagt hat, äh Zensurzensur, Uploadfilter sind scheiße
nicht, dass wir ähm ne, nicht dass wir uns einfach die nächsten Idioten wählen, sondern dass wir einfach, dass man einfach erkennt,
Aha. So, das ist hier äh wir haben das jetzt mal gesehen, deswegen versuche ich auch die die tragische Rolle des Axel Voss zu würdigen,
der eben versagt hat, der hatte eine Anforderung, eine berufliche, eine Karriereanforderung und diese hat er nicht erfüllt,
und hat damit einfach richtig dicken Stein ins Hungelnest geworfen.
Und jetzt müssen halt ähm hoffentlich die Hummeln checken. Warum.
Wir als nächstes anderem einen anderen äh jetzt hätte ich Imker gesagt, aber Hummeln haben ja keinen Imker. Hummeln die Hummeln müssten halt jetzt gucken.
Warum habe ich überhaupt Hummeln genommen? Weil die, weil die so cool sind. Hummeln sind cool. Aber ähm.
Wenn du meinst, okay, ich lasse dich jetzt.
Sind auf jeden Fall cooler als Hornissen. Ähm.
Und ähm.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen Sendungszill, Moment, sind cool.
Ich.
Okay, aber ich glaube, wir drehen jetzt im Kreis. Wir machen jetzt folgendes.
Ich fürchte, dass wir gerade auch so ein bisschen abgleiten in eine äh Strategiediskussion zwischen zwei Aktivisten und Lobbyisten.
Ja und vielleicht auch so.
Wir gehen einfach zum nächsten Thema.
Genau die zwei alten Typen, die die äh die junge Protestbewegung nicht mehr verstehen. Also ich will äh auch weitermachen. Wir haben nämlich noch so viel was passiert ist. Ähm es ist
die Woche auch ein Blackout der Wikipedia A passiert in vielen Sprachversionen. Ähm insgesamt waren's die
deutsche, tschechische, dänische und slowakische Wigipedia, die am Donnerstag, den einundzwanzigsten März, äh, für vierundzwanzig Stunden offline gingen und äh dann auch gleich mit so einem schwarzen Screen und einer Protestmeldung
und dort haben sie dann auch gleich angegeben. Ähm äh dass wir ähm.
Dass sie.
Ah, jetzt ist mir eingefallen, was die Hummeln lernen müssen. Also, die hummeln, die müssen halt sehen, das war jetzt halt ein Depp,
Ja? Und wir müssen jetzt nicht alle Menschen Scheiße finden, sondern wir machen einfach weiter und sehen zu, dass wir uns von
solchen Leuten fernhalten und die irgendwie nicht in die Position bringen, dass sie uns irgendwie einen Stein gegen unser Hummelnnest werfen können,
Ich weiß schon, ich will diese Metapher noch zu Ende führen.
Gut, hätten wir das auch.
Und deswegen die Hummeln sind nicht nur cool, die Hummeln bleiben cool, weißt du? Die sind so, ey, okay, Deps so, den müssen wir jetzt hier mal kurz zurechtweisen, aber wir wir ähm wir wir verlieren jetzt nicht den Glauben an die Menschheit, ja? Die Hummeln dürfen,
an die Menschheit verlieren. Oder an Europa.
Genau. Okay. Ähm äh weiterentdeckst. Also wir hatten etwas, das eigentlich so noch nie passiert ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob's jemals schon mal einen Blackout, der.
Deutschen WG Pedia gab. Ähm es gab Banner zu politischen Themen, aber der Blackout ist ja wirklich so die Ultima Ratio, das ist das härteste Mittel, was die Wikipedia hat, um zu protestieren.
Und das haben sie hier gezogen ähm und eben wie gesagt den vier Sprachversionen sogar, also fünf betroffene Länder in Europa,
dürfte auch nochmal wirklich äh in den nicht deutschsprachigen Ländern dazu verholfen haben, dass dieses Thema überhaupt wieder auf die Agenda kommt. Äh hier muss man den Kontext auch mit verstehen, dass
Viele Medien berichten nicht über dieses Thema und wenn dann sehr einseitig, weil es hier äh
fundamentale Geschäftsinteressen gibt mit Artikel elf dem Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger
weil ähm auch äh öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehanstalten äh oft eines äh Meinung zum Urheberrecht haben, äh die sich nicht deckt mit dem, was zum Beispiel in der Wikipedia geleb.
Ähm und äh dadurch
Sind solche radikalen Aktionen etwas, das durchaus äh in die in die öffentliche Wahrnehmung überhaupt mal ähm reinbringt, dass es hier zwei Seiten einer Debatte gibt und dass das nicht nur a tolles, neues Urheberreicht ist,
Ja
Wo noch diskutiert wird, äh also jetzt gerade Sonntag, als wir dies hier aufnehmen, ist Portugal Frankreich, Italien, galizische, astorianische,
Sprachversion der WG Pedia dort wird noch diskutiert, Frankreich, wer hier am spannendsten
weil in Frankreich eben die das Meinungsbild sehr radikal nur in die in die Urheberrechtsseite geht und äh dass das halt hier eben auch um Meinungsfreiheit geht und um um Netzfreiheit.
Das sind Sachen, die äh vielleicht nur mit so einem Protestschritt überhaupt mal Leuten dort bewusst werden. Ähm wo schon sicher ist, ist ein äh Blackout in Italien, der kommt am Montag, das ist hat die Community schon
entschieden, was auch wiederum sehr spannend ist, weil wir in Italien ja die Regierung haben
also mit dem ähm äh fünf Sternen und der Liga, aber ebenso die klassischen Sozialdemokraten und Konservativen, die auch viele Sitze im Europaparlament haben. Ähm, da noch nicht auf Linie sind.
Das wäre sozusagen auch nochmal ein wichtiger Schubser. Man muss das ganze Thema
Pesch sehen, es es reicht absolut nicht aus, wenn wir hier irgendwie Deutschland und Österreich und Niederlande und Polen haben, sondern wir brauchen eine viel größere Koalition
und ähm was was man auch vielleicht noch sagen müsste, die Berichterstattung über die Demonstrationen war durchaus sehr groß. Ich weiß es nur im deutschsprachigen Raum
aber in vielen anderen EU-Ländern ist da gar nicht drüber berichtet worden. Das muss nicht nur als verschwörungstheoretische Gründe haben, es gab auch eine
Brexit-Demonstration äh äh jetzt diesen Samstag, wo äh glaube ich auch
unheimlich viele Menschen waren, da habe ich jetzt keine Zahlen, aber ich weiß nur, dass es dort auch eine Petition gibt, äh, gegen den Brexit und für ein zweites Referendum, die auch gerade die fünf Millionen Unterschriften,
die sozusagen jetzt die Change dot org Petition eingeholt hat. Ähm wir sind jetzt nicht böse auf die Briten
Äh das ist äh genauso ein legitimes Anliegen, nicht aus dem.
Prägt Europa rauszukommen, wie auch Fridays for Future. Wir retten den Planeten und dem Brexit und das Internet. Das schaffen wir,
Ähm wer wer aber beim Internet auch noch ähm
das sind alles so große Sachen, dass man die hier so als Randnotiz erwähnt ist irgendwie crazy, aber wir hatten auch Banner am einundzwanzigsten März auf Redit, Twitch und Pornhub.
Was ist das, was.
Redit? Äh kennst du, da wo die ganzen Kommentare geschrieben werden, Twitch äh ist ein ähm,
einer Plattform für Livestreams äh und Porn Hub äh eine
Pornoseite äh und Pornhub dot com hat auch äh auf äh Plätsch verlinkt, also alle drei haben eigentlich auf Pletsch verlinkt äh was äh für sehr viel Traffic gesorgt hat auf unserer Kampagnenseite. Äh und auch.
Auf der Seite geblieben oder.
Ich habe jetzt die Statistiken nicht angeschaut, aber es war signifikant, mehr Traffic, wir wussten dann zwischenzeitlich Cloud faire einschalten dazu, aber weil,
die ist prinzipiell schon so gebaut, dass sie skaliert. Und wir haben auch äh prinzipiell unendlich viele parallele Anrufe, die wir über dieses System abfahren können, weil wir dahinter TVs Backen verwenden. Äh die Kreditkarte glüht halt in diesen Momenten, ähm aber
das darauf sind wir vorbereitet, ja? Ähm! Das das ist so einfach, was so am Donnerstag noch passiert ist, noch bevor überhaup,
die Demo war und das hat man eben auch so ein bissel hat mir die Schockquellen im Europaparlament noch gehört. Ähm, dass das Thema halt dann doch bei einigen Leuten angekommen ist, die sich davor noch weggeduckt haben
Ähm ja äh.
Wer hat am meisten gebracht.
Äh lustigerweise war ähm na
Twitch und Redit waren größer als Porn-Hub, auch wenn Porn-Hub glaube ich, die sechs oder siebtgrößte Webseite der Welt ist, ähm aber die Community ist von äh Twitch und Redit sind natürlich viel äh bewusster mit diesem Thema, als zu der
typische Pornhab-Nutzer, der vielleicht grad an was anderes denkt.
Der relativ konkrete Aufgabe dann die äh.
Ich habe das aber gegenüber meinen Kind so gerechtfertigt, dass wir halt über diesen Weg einen direkten Draht zu den Politikern haben. Ähm und dass dann.
Äh also das, das ist da passiert, was ähm ich jetzt auch noch eben als weiteres Argument so, also zuerst nochmal ready, Twitch und Porn habe,
alles betroffene Plattformen von Artikel dreizehn, alles Plattformen, die einen Uploadfilter,
etablieren müssten, die sofort haftbar wären für ähm jedes Gedicht, das sich in einem Video versteckt, das bei ihnen hochgeladen wird oder als Text reingestellt wird. Ähm und,
da ist schon auch äh eine direkte Betroffenheit dieser Plattformen da. Äh den Start-up-Brief habe ich schon erwähnt. Ich finde das ganz spannend, eben gerade auch,
du bringst ja immer das Argument, das wird Google stärken. Jetzt sagen auch die Firmen, die mit Google konkurrieren, es wird uns schaden und das ist auch nochmal ganz wichtig,
die sich jetzt noch vor der Abstimmung Gehör verschaffen mit diesem Punkt,
Wer sich auch nochmal Gehör verschafft hat, ist äh eine Kollektion von zweihundert Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern,
ebenso die führendsten Institute, Wissenschaftsinstitute im Bereich Intellecture Poperty Law
Und äh wir verlinken auch hier wiederum ähm das Statement, weil ich will, dass ihr all diese Originalquellen auch äh verfügbar habt
wenn ihr vielleicht am Montag noch mit Abgeordneten reden wollt und ich zitiere hier nur einen Satz aus äh diesem.
Dieses Sacho Case.
Ein Polocymakers Nito Techno. Ähm also deutlicher könnte man eigentlich nicht sein und das
teilt sich dann halt einfach irgendwie so in dem Reinigen von Pornhub und und und lauter Demo mit hunderttausenden Menschen über die Wissenschaftler, die UN. Es.
Ist langsam habe ich auch so das Gefühl, wir haben fast alles gemacht, was wir machen konnten. Ähm aber dann kommt wieder der nächste Gegenangriff.
Und äh der, der ist im Grunde gleich am Samstag ähm nach äh schon während die Demos schon liefen, passiert
Als äh Daniel Kaspari, der äh Leiter der äh CDU CSU-Delegation im Europaparlament, also der Chef aller konservativer Abgeordneter aus Deutschland, im Europaparlament
Der hat ein Interview der Bild-Zeitung gegeben und da äh hat er auch
mehr oder weniger allen Demonstranten unterstellt, ähm jetzt vierhundert äh fünfzig Euro von Google bekommen zu haben. Werdlich hat er gesagt, nun wird offensichtlich versucht, auch mit gekauften Demonstranten
Die Verabschiedung des Urheberrechts zu verhindern. Bis zu vierhundertfünfzig Euro werden von einer sogenannten NGO für die Demoteilnahme.
Geld scheint zumindest teilweise von großen amerikanischen Internetkonzernen zu stammen, wenn.
Wenn amerikanische Konzerne mit massivem Einsatz von Desinformationen und gekauften Demonstranten versuchen, Gesetze zu verhindern, ist unsere Demokratie bedroht.
Ähm, wie gesagt, das ist eine Aussage äh eines eines äh deutschen Spitzenpolitikers in einem sehr auflagenstark,
Medium in Deutschland. Ähm man könnte sich jetzt noch irgendwie wundern, hat dir das vielleicht so dahin gesagt und und dann bei der Abnahme ist es ihm durchgerutscht äh und sie waren sich erzöhnt, dass sie das dann gelesen haben. Nein, es hat nun auch noch der Twit
der CDU CSU Fraktion im Europaparlament genau
den letzten Satz mit dem, was ich jetzt zitiert habe, äh so herausgenommen und getwittert
Also das ist eine bewusste Aussage, um auf diese Demonstrationen zu reagieren. Ähm
gekauft, der Monstranten ist natürlich so ein ein rechtes Sprachbild, äh wenn man's historisch betrachtet und ein Vorwurf ähm um um sozusagen insgesamt ähm demokratischen Protest.
Versammlungsfreiheit zu diskreditieren ähm und es gab dann natürlich auch wiederum einen einen riesigen Backclash auf Social Media, dass Menschen irgendwie
so wie du jetzt gerade reagiert haben, auch teils namenhafte öffentlich-rechtliche Journalisten, die gemeint haben, haben sie jetzt gerade meinen Sohn, der demonstrieren war als gekauften Demonstranten bezeichnet
Ähm natürlich wenn man die Rechnung macht, vierhundertfünfzig Euro, sagen wir äh zweihunderttausend Demonstranten in ganz Europa, das war teuer für Google
Also muss man ungefähr bei neunzig Millionen. Ähm
also das ist äh hat den den wie zu erwartenden Shitstorm ausgelöst. Ähm aber eben auch wiederum nur in dem
Internetmedien, Bildzeitung, glaube ich, noch keine Reaktion da drauf äh für Menschen, die sich halt eher von Totholzmedien informieren, äh die für die bleibt diese Aussage jetzt einfach mal so stehen,
und äh das ist glaube ich auch genau das, was damit bezweckt werden sollte.
Was, warum erlauben wir denn und solche Verschwörungstheoretik.
Ja, also das Wichtige ist, er verwendet hier auch die Begriffe Desinformation und äh demokratiegefährdend. Und ähm.
Grenzt schon so als trumpsche Logik, dass man, dass man das, was man gerade betreibt, den anderen vorwirft. Äh und,
ja, also ich meine es gibt jetzt auch schon die,
wie zu erwartenden Fact-Checkings dazu äh auf äh Bildblock und auch auf n-tv, die wir verlinken werden
Weil was hier Herr Kaspari scheinbar gemacht hat ist. Wir waren ja beide in Brüssel die Woche. Du bist äh bemerkt haben, dass da irgendwie
recht viele Aktivisten aus ganz Europa auch gerade im Europarlament waren, die Klinken geputzt haben und nochmal versucht haben mit den Abgeordneten zu sprechen. Edri
nämlich gerade ein ähm ein Programm gehabt, wo sie sich äh Geld von der Open Society Foundation beantragt haben, dass sie nochmal ähm,
Ehrenamtliche Aktivisten nach Brüssel holen können.
Was du hier, du hast das doch hier in der äh letzten.
Das ist dieser Teil der Action Week, die Idri jetzt gerade macht und äh
dieses Geld davon sind fünfzehntausend Euro, vierhundertfünfzig Euro pro Person, äh mit dem haben sie ungefähr so zwanzig, dreißig Leute finanziert bekommen. Ähm, ich habe den Großteil davon
auch getroffen in Brüssel, wie gesagt, die kamen alle dann am Dienstag rein und haben sich reingehängt. Ähm.
Das heißt, dreihundertfünfzig Euro haben die für die Anreise bekommen und zwar zweimal fünfzig Euro für Übernachtungen in Brüssel und fünfzig Euro.
Fünfzig Euro für 'ne Überwachung in Brüssel ist,
sehr wenig. Also da schaffst du's vielleicht irgendwo nur Absteige, ein Hotel äh Stadtmitte kriegst du auf keinen Fall mit sowas. Ja,
außer du hast irgendwie viele Leute, die sich ein Airbnb leisten.
Aber diese vierhundertfünfzig Euro, wenn man sich dann die Leute anschaut, die da gekommen sind, das waren zum allergrößten Teil äh Ehrenamtliche, das war nicht.
Bords waren das, das waren alle.
Ähm aber das das sind eben grade eben nicht so, ich kenne die ganzen NGOs aus Europa, das war nicht deren Mitarbeiter, wir waren glaube ich die einzigen.
Aus Nabrüssler NGO sind, die vor Ort waren, aber es waren halt die ganzen Ehrenamtlichen. Aus äh Spanien, Portugal, Großbritannien, Niederlanden, denen das Thema wichtig ist und die nochmal was tun wollten.
Und
Äh scheinbar hat Herr Kaspari diese zwanzig, dreißig Leute, die alle vierhundertfünfzig Euro Reisekostenerstattung bekommen haben,
aufgemünzt auf Google zahlt hier ein zweihunderttausend Demonstranten vierhundertfünfzig Euro, ja? Und.
Wie gesagt, dieses Interview ist parallel zur Demonstration erschienen
Also er wird sich wahrscheinlich ausgerichtet haben, da kommen sicherlich nicht viele Leute und wenn's vielleicht ein paar tausend sind, werfen wir ihnen mal vor, dass sie alle bezahlt sind,
Wir haben da so irgendwie komische äh Dinge gehört, nachgeprüft haben wir es nicht. Man könnte das jetzt Desinformation nennen, weil hier eben äh bewusst
Eine Falschaussage getroffen wurde, um eine politische Debatte zu beeinflussen, die Ideen nicht entlang der Fakten ist. Äh Judith Sabler ist das nicht, Herr Kaspari hat keine einzelnen Person vorgeworfen
bezahlter Weise zu demonstrieren, dann könnte man das vielleicht klagen, aber nachdem man da keine einzelne Person angesprochen hat
äh kann man ihnen das wahrscheinlich auch zivilrechtlich nicht vorhalten. Ähm und das äh die Bild hat ja nur ihn zitiert mit dem, was er gesagt hat, die sind sowieso fein raus
Aber das.
Weißt du, wenn dem wenn dem jetzt mal einer stecken würde, ne? Was so ein durchschnittlicher Lobbyist.
Der bei ihm jeden Tag morgens auf der Matte steht, ja? Was der für ein Monatsgehalt hat.
Und was der für eine Reisekostenabrechnung am Ende.
Tages schickt, ja? Mit Flügen nach Brüssel, nach Berlin und wo man sonst noch hin muss und schön die äh Übernachtungen.
Und die Verpflegungspauschalen für die unterschiedlichen äh Reisen innerhalb Europas, ja? Ich kenne ja so Reiseabrechnungen, ne? Wenn ihr die mal sehen würde.
Meinst du, da würde der eh nicht.
Der ist bei der Union und er hat sowieso als Europaparlament da ja äh reist er auf eine sehr komfortable Art und Weise, was gut ist. Wir wollen, dass sie aus Brüssel rauskommen und ganz Europa sehen. Aber
ähm ja, der, der, der Vorwurf ist so dermaßen aus dem Kontext gerissen und dann dann auch noch tendenziös formuliert. Ähm,
wer, wer auch nur irgendwie die Fotos von den Demos gesehen haben, äh geschweige denn wirklich bei einer Bar, was bei unseren Hörerinnen wahrscheinlich eher der Fall war. Der weiß, dass das so weit ab jeder Realität ist. Und trotzdem, es gibt ein Zielpublikum für
Genau dieses Publikum ist diese Aussage gemacht. Ähm das ist alles eine Manipulation von Google. Wir wir sehen ja auch so eine gewisse ähm.
Das ist ein bissl wie bei Donald Trump, ja? Ich mache Aussagen, wo ich weiß, die andere Seite der Gesellschaft wird
Sich in die Haare greifen, Fazial palmieren und wird sich einfach nur denken, oh mein Gott, wie kannst du nur, aber dann habe ich
die andere Hälfte oder das Drittel der Bevölkerung, die ich vielleicht
dem Orkeoki gibt's Sinn, ja vielleicht sind die alle von Google gekauft, ja. Die Kinder, die jetzt von Artikel dreizehn reden, die sind vielleicht auch von YouTube manipuliert worden, ne? Vielleicht kann YouTube sowas wissen wir ja nicht.
Komm jetzt, ey, weil also da hast du einmal okay, also das ist wirklich äh.
Oh je, ist das, also das ist halt so traurig, ja? Ich meine, wenn das, wenn das in irgendeinem anderen Kontext passiert, dann ist das eine eine wunderschöne Maßnahme zum zur politischen Bildung oder zum Heranführen äh junger Menschen an den
ne, an politische Kultur und Auseinandersetzung und jetzt ist das also kommen.
Na ja. Thomas, wir haben uns eigentlich vorgenommen, eine kurze Sendung zu machen und ich sehe, dass es das hier ähnlich entgleitet wie mir üblicherweise mit Tim.
Deswegen darf ich dich dazu darf ich dich zur Abstimmung führen? Ja oder.
Äh es gibt eine schöne Seite, wo man sein Demogeld beantragen kann, die verlinken wir noch. Aber jetzt äh wäre es mir noch ein großes Anliegen gewesen. Ähm kurz über
die Abstimmung am Dienstag zu sprechen und die Formalien davon. Äh also wie diese Abstimmung eigentlich ähm ablaufen wird. Man kann
der im Livestream beiwohnen und was so die möglichen Art Comes sind,
Also die äh Abstimmung und Debatte werden beide am äh Dienstag, den sechsundzwanzigsten März, äh zweitausendneunzehn in Straßburg äh passieren
Die Debatte beginnt um neun Uhr und der Urheberrecht ist gleich der erste Tagesordnungspunkt. Also da wird dann circa vierzig Minuten lang,
und es werden die verschiedenen politischen Parteien nochmal Rehnerinnen aufstellen, die.
Die einzelnen Positionen darlegen. Da hört man dann nochmal innen Nachel, alles was wichtig ist zu dieser Debatte. Ich rechne auch damit, dass es da einige sehr gute und wiederum sehr haarstreibende Statements geben wird
Ähm und der wirkliche Wot, die Abstimmung passiert dann äh in einem Votingblot zwischen zwölf Uhr dreißig und vierzehn Uhr dreißig, wo es so ungefähr in der, in der Mitte davon äh ITIM zwölf von zweiundzwanzig das Urheberrecht drankommt,
Wir verlinken hier jetzt auch noch eine Votingliste,
Die ähm wir gerade heute veröffentlicht haben, da seht ihr sozusagen was wir uns wünschen würden, wie die Abgeordneten
abstimmen. Ähm es ist ja in Straßburg so, dass man ähm.
Dass da elektronisch abgestimmt wird, also jeder Abgeordnete hat ein Kärtchen und dann drei Knöpfe, auf die er drücken kann, ja, nein, Enthaltung
Und man glaubt nicht, wie effizient diese Parlamentarier darin sind, abzustimmen. Also die schaffen's wirklich innerhalb von fünf Minuten durch so eine vierzigseitige Votinglist durchzugehen. Äh wenn sie eine Sache können, dann als Stimmvieh schneller durch so eine Liste durchzugehen, deswegen.
Ja aber das ist wenn du Leute, wenn du Leute was professionell machen lässt, ne? Also was weiß ich
professionell kassieren. Die älteren von euch erinnern sich, es hat relativ lange gedauert bis ähm bei Aldi die Menschen, die dort gearbeitet haben, auch ähm im Scannerkasten bekommen haben, ja. Die konn
tippen.
Das war Wahnsinn auf den auf diesen Tastaturen, ne? Hat sie noch irgendwie Sachen angucken mussten und die Preise eingeben mussten. Ähm wenn du dir anschaust, wie Menschen Kugelschreiber zusammenbauen oder ähm,
Menschen bei Foxcorn iPhones, das ist erstaunlich, was für eine Professionalität Menschen in in langweiligen, störenden Tätigkeiten entwickeln, für die sie bezahlt werden.
So natürlich auch für das Abstimmen im Parlament.
Und im Grunde es ist ja auch für die meisten Abgeordneten in dem Fall die haben einen Zettel vor sich liegen,
wo draufsteht plus minus und das ist halt stimmig dafür oder stimme ich dagegen und ähm
Dinkzettel, den die da vor sich liegen haben sozusagen für unsere Seite der Debat
den könnt ihr euch äh unter der Verlinkung bei Ebicenterwerk seinen Dokumenten runterladen. Und wenn ihr den Zettel vor euch liegen habt und den Livestream schaut, könnt ihr heute wirklich in Echtzeit mitverfolgen. Ähm wie es ausgehen wird.
Und ähm wenn man so eine Votinglist vor sich hat, man hat hier eine Tabelle ähm mit äh Zeilen für jeden Änderungsantrag oder für jede Abstimmung
Und äh in den Spalten sieht man halt, dass äh jeder Änderungsantrag oder jedes Italien, was abgestimmt, äh, wird eben ein Subcheck hat, eine Nummer, eine Partei oder Gruppe von Abgeordneten über die sie eingebracht wurde. Ähm
RCV, das steht für, also ob er seine namentliche Abstimmung ist, ob ich im Nachhinein wisse, wie die einzelnen Abgeordneten abgestimmt haben oder nur das Ergebnis kenne.
Ist sehr wichtig für die politische Nachvollziehbarkeit und hier wird's natürlich auch ein Rohcollboard geben
Ähm und dann am Ende nochmal so eben Wort, also ob ich jetzt hier mit Plus oder mit Minus stimmen werde. Eigentlich ist nur diese Wotspalte, jene, die ähm äh.
Die am Ende über darüber entscheidet, ob äh.
Genau, das ist, was die Parteien, sozusagen, es gibt da auch auf der Parlamentswebseite ein Wort, was man sich runterladen kann. Man kann sich seine eigene Votingliste basteln. Machen auch alle.
Und ähm oft übernehmen das eben die Parteien, aber bei so einem Thema, wo die Parteien ja alle gespalten sind, ist es auch wichtig, dass diese Votinglisten
richtig sind. Und am Ende hat man noch eine Spalte mit den Remarx, weil was hier wichtig ist
Im Europaparlament ist es so, dass und wahrscheinlich in jedem Parlament stelle ich mir vor, die die Änderungsanträge, die am meisten ändern, zuerst abgestimmt werden und dann, der, der am zweitmeisten ändert.
Moment, Moment, Moment, ich komme jetzt nicht so genau hinterher. Ich habe jetzt dieses äh dieses Tableing-Service äh Ding vor mir, ne? Ähm da sind ja jetzt schon Plus und Minuszeichen drin.
Genau, weil wir die ausgefüllt haben, sozusagen das ist, was wir.
Ach so, okay, das heißt, das brauchen wir jetzt nur noch auszudrucken und ähm in Straßburg auszulegen. Dann.
Mehr oder weniger, ja? Ja. Ähm natürlich vielleicht gibt es solche Abgeordnete äh ja doch ich weiß, es gibt auch solche Abgeordnete, aber,
Grunde ist es äh sozusagen ein Teil der Mechanik, wie abgestimmt wird und äh wenn man diese Mechanik selber vorliegen hat, kann man eben auch dieses Ritual des Abstimmens entschlüsseln und weiß auch eben in Echtzeit gleich was rausgekommen ist.
Okay, das heißt, wir können hier, wir müssen jetzt nur nochmal ein paar Mal vierhundertfünfzig Euro von Google nehmen, damit wir ein paar Leute nach Straßburg fliegen können, die euren Ausdruck, den da hinlegen und dann tippen die das so runter und äh schwuppdiwupp ist der Drops gelutscht.
Ich habe halt wirklich die Angst, dass jetzt gleich auf FAZ seiner Titel kommt. Eine Google finanzierter Podcast Stifte zur Wahl, weil Manipulation an Cybercyber.
Ja. Ähm.
Äh bei der Debatte wird leider nicht nicht inhaltlich argumentiert, aber äh ich bleibe beim Prozedere an Gesicht der Zeit.
Ja, erklär mir aber noch bitte, ganz, ich habe gerade eh, wenn du in die Shownotes guckst, die Sendung grade, um alle anderen Themen gekürzt. Ähm wir wir bleiben, das wird jetzt das Ende hier, deswegen können wir uns doch ein bisschen mehr Zeit dafür nehmen. Ähm.
Die da steht jetzt ist das gibt's da äh Verknüpfung.
Genau, das steht hier in den Remarx, weil zum wenn man hier mal runtergehen Artikel elf, Artikel dreizehn, hier gibt es
Mehrere Änderungsanträge von mehreren politischen Parteien oder einzelnen Abgeordneten, die die Streichung dieser Artikel vorsehen. Und nur wenn diese Streichung die radikalste Änderung nicht angenommen wird, dann
Gehst du überhaupt erst zu den äh äh nächsten Änderungsantrag, dem eine andere Version von diesem AT1 oder dreizehn ist, beim Dreizehner gibt es auch noch einen alternativen Text
der zuletzt abgestimmt wird, ähm der eine minimale Verbesserung ist, aber eigentlich das Grundproblem genauso
beibehält und deswegen sind wir bei beiden äh Artikel elf um dreizehn für die Schlösschung. Das macht jetzt auch im Moment mehr Sinn
Wenn wir jetzt eine klare Entscheidung gegen Upload-Filter haben, dann
gibt's auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit noch, dass der Rat im Text einfach zustimmt, äh, ohne Artikel dreizehn, das ist, wir kommen schneller noch zu einer fixwertigen Reform, anstatt jetzt nochmal irgendwie über einen neuen Text zu verhandeln
Ähm ja, aber du siehst diese Effizienz sozusagen in der rechten Spalte und da siehst du, wenn etwas angenommen.
Sagen. Conditionals ist der richtige Begriff. Okay?
Und und hier ist sozusagen
gleich in der ersten Zeile gibt es ein Proposal Rececticuem Proposel Toure Jack, der Commission Proposal, also der erste Antrag über dem abgestimmt wird äh ist gleich, ob wir das komplette Ding,
verhindern wollen, ob diese gesamte Reform abgelehnt wird,
der wurde eingebracht von der IFT, das ist so die die fünf Sterne sind zum Beispiel in dieser Partei auch die sind in dieser Par.
Fünf Sterne müssen wir sagen, nicht fünf Sterne Deluxe, sondern.
Genau die italienische äh äh linkspopulistische Partei, die auch im Moment in der Regierung ist, ähm, die auch im Rat gegen das Gesetz sind,
Und hier die haben sozusagen gemeinsam mit ihrer Parteienfamilie sozusagen gleich die Streichung von den Dingern gebracht. Was einen eine Lösung wäre, dann hätten wir halt kein neues Oberrecht, aber wir hätten halt auch Artikel dreizehn und elf verhindert
Ähm und wenn dieser Antrag angenommen wird, dann siehst du hier dann rechts in den äh Remarx, dann würden wir sozusagen sofort weiterspringen
auf äh das Ende der Voting-Liste, weil damit ist der Drops gelutscht. Damit ist das gesamte Gesetz ab.
Ähm und äh wenn das aber nicht passiert, also wenn man nicht eine, eine Mehrheit gegen die gesamte Reform hat, geht man eben weiter. Und normalerweise,
Würde es jetzt einfach nur eine Abstimmung geben über den Text selber, wenn die angenommen wird, ist der Text angenommen, das Gesetz ist fertig und wir haben verloren.
Hier gibt's aber äh einen schönen prozedualen Trick. Es wird ein äh Abgeordneter in diesem Moment aufstehen,
und verlangen, dass die Änderungsanträge vor dem Trilog Equiment abgestimmt werden. Und diese eine Person triggert dann einen Vot in diesem Moment.
Wo alle Abgeordneten abstimmen müssen, dass es kein Wort, wir werden nicht wissen, wie die einzelnen Abgeordneten abgestimmt haben. Wir brauchen hier eine Mehrheit, dass die Änderungsanträge zuerst abgestimmt werden vor dem Tridoga Gremen
Nur wenn wir hier eine Mehrheit haben, haben wir überhaupt die Chance über Änderungsanträge wie die Löschung abzustimmen. Wenn wir diesem.
Thomas kannst du kannst du das nochmal, kannst du das nochmal also ich kann dir jetzt folgen, weil ich dieses diese Tabelle vor mir habe, ne. Aber äh das heißt nochmal kurz.
Okay, ich versuch's einfach mal. Also wir müssen am Anfang mal abstimmen, ob wir überhaupt über äh abstimmen. Wir müssen.
Also jemand sagt, ich möchte erst die Emantmants abstimmen.
Wieso ist diese, wieso steht das überhaupt zur Debatte? Das ist doch sollte doch naheliegend sein, dass man erst die Emantmants und das komplette Ding abstimmt, bevor man am Ende über alles abstimm.
Es wäre so logisch, aber äh nachdem da hier eben der Trikolog schon fertig ist, äh sind die Rose Pacis scheinbar so, dass du hier eigentlich ist, ist das Ganze auf Tuch äh Winken gepolt.
Ach so, das wäre also das wäre so ein bisschen, aber das ist äh eigentlich wie so ein Brexit, ne.
Ja, also.
Wir machen erstmal erstmal stimmen wir dafür und danach überlegen wir uns, wie wir das denn, wie wir das dann ausgestalten wollen. Also okay.
Ja, ja, es ist, es hat schon was davon. Also ob auf jeden Fall.
Doch ein. Und wenn da steht One Member of Parlament äh Will Stand-up to As, das heißt äh.
Ich weiß nicht, wer es ist, aber wahrscheinlich ist es Julia Reder, ich weiß es aber wirklich.
Ja, ich will jetzt Na.
Aber es wäre eigentlich wär's gescheitert, wenn's eben nicht Julia ist, sondern jemand, der wirklich aus der Mitte des Parlaments kommt, der in in aller politischen Richtungen ähm anerkannt ist, also im besten Fall ja, jemand, der, der, wo es nicht sofort,
persönliche Gegenreaktionen gäbe, ja? Und äh ja, dann dann wird halt zuerst mal noch über zwei ähm.
Provisional Clemens abgestimmt oder das Commission Statement, das sind einfach so prozeduale Dinge und dann wird's spannend, wenn wir eben zuerst über Artikel elf und dann über Artikel dreizehn abstimmen. Und äh in beiden Fällen gibt es eben
Streichung dieser Artikel als Änderungsantrag und ähm wir
hoffen, dass wir bei beiden eine Mehrheit bekommen. Wir sehen die Änderungsanträge zur Streichung dieser Artikel, sind wirklich von äh einer ganz breiten Koalition von Abgeordneten eingebracht worden. Also ich glaube, wir sollen um die hundertzwanzig Abgeordnete,
die insgesamten Änderungsantrag für die Streichung von Artikel dreizehn unterstützt haben. Ein wirklich von Sozialdemokraten eben über äh IFD, also von YouTube bis Tschinke Stella, die konservativen, die Liberalen
sogar die Torres und die Grünen, also da gibt's breite Unterstützung schon mal diesen Änderungsantrag zu haben.
Und mein, meine Vermutung ist, wir werden wahrscheinlich den.
Die Abstimmung darüber, dass Änderungsanträge zugelassen werden, die werden wir gewinnen. Dann bei den Änderungsan.
Einfach weil weil dieser eine schon von so vielen eingebracht wurde, sodass da jetzt und.
Gerade im Groove sind und sagen, komm, wir stimmen jetzt hier, die kriegen wir auch noch weggestimmt. So.
Also bei bei einem Thema, wo um die zweihunderttausend Menschen auf die Straße gehen, zu sagen, okay und wir stimmen nicht drüber ab,
das sitzt auch der Großteil des Hauses wird wiedergewählt werden,
das willst du dir nicht leisten, weil da da geht's ja noch nicht mal um die Sache, sondern einfach nur prozedoral, kriegen sie die Chance, dass wir darüber abstimmen. Und ähm.
Dann ist es halt wirklich die Frage,
Bei elf und dreizehn haben wir hier eine Mehrheit für die Löschung von beiden oder wenigstens einem der beiden Artikel ähm und ich glaube hier wird es wahnsinnig knapp werden. Also wir sind in.
Gibt Votkans, die in die Richtung gehen, das ist wirklich.
Zehn, fünfzehn Stimmen liegt, die den Unterschied ausmachen. Ähm und
Das heißt, es wird wahnsinnig knapp und wie ich zuletzt auch schon bei der letzten Sendung sagte, auch wichtig sein, wer überhaupt dort ist. Also Abgeordneten, die nicht in Straßburg sind, nächste Woche sollten wirklich ans Kreuz genagelt werden, weil äh man muss sich hier auch einfach der,
der der Verantwortung stellen. Und hier ähm äh eine Position beziehen, dafür ist das Thema äh viel zu wichtig,
Ja und nachdem Enderungsanträge angenommen oder abgelehnt wurden, gibt's dann noch die Entscheidung, ob der Vot, ob das äh Dossier insgesamt angenommen wird in dieser veränderten Fassung oder ob's für dieses Gesetz dann keine Mehrheit mehr gibt.
Also haben wir eine Urheberrechtsreform. Ohne Artikel elf oder dreizehn? Oder wenn Artikel elf oder dreizehn oder beide fallen, gibt's dann gar kein neues Gesetz.
Dass es zuletzt nochmal die Abstimmung, die ähm.
Die den Parlamentariern ah die sie zu treffen haben sozusagen der letzte Vot, seid ihr jetzt mit dem Endresultat zufrieden oder nicht?
Ach so, da könnt ihr also jetzt könnte es sein, dass äh vielleicht Leute, die gesamte Urheberrechtsreform nur wegen Artikel elf und dreizehn gerne hätten, dass die dann sagen, ne.
Wenn mir die vorher schon rausgevotet wurden, dann äh will ich lieber gar keine Urheberrechtsreform mehr, ne? Weil dann kann ich ja nochmal einen neuen Versuch machen.
Wäre eigentlich schade, weil eigentlich wollen wir, dass die, dass das Urheberrecht mal äh abgetatet wird und es gibt sinnvolle Aspekte in diesem Gesetz. Ist nicht perfekt, aber man kann damit leben und man kann damit arbeiten. Nur eben mit elf und dreizehn ist es,
eine ein ein nicht tragbares Gesetz. Man muss abge.
Kannst du mir jetzt noch kurz dazu sagen, jetzt sehe ich auf diesem Stimmzettel, da steht elf und dreizehn. Das hatten wir aber schon gehört, dass die eigentlich ähm fünfzehn und siebzehn sind.
Ja, aber.
Weil sie neu, weil neu nummeriert wurde, um den finalen Text nicht mit irgendwelchen äh neuen A und sonst was drin zu haben, sondern einfach einen Artikel schön nach dem anderen sauber nummeriert, keine Unterverzweigungen. Ähm.
Wieso spiegelt sich das jetzt auf diesen ähm auf diesen Abstimmungszettel nicht wieder.
Ich kann sie nicht hundertprozentig sicher sagen, mein Etikette wäre, weil äh die Bereinigung von der du sprichst
muss sich die Nummerierung ändern, die kommt von Leal Services, das heißt da wird wirklich der Text nochmal juristisch nachgeschliffen, das was im Trilog Equiment drinnen stand, wo man eben wir machen jetzt irgendwie einen sieben A hypothetisch gesprochen weil den fügen wir hier sozusagen dazwischen ein.
Und nachher gehst du sauber durch, nummerierst sauber nochmal von oben nach unten und schaust, dass irgendwie die einheitliche Thermonologie, Beispielsetzung Pipapo alles richtig ist.
Parallel dazu gibt's aber die Übersetzung in die äh vierundzwanzig Amtssprachen der Europäischen Union. Und die muss passieren, bevor das denn im Plenum liegt
Das ist so eine der wichtigen Regeln, also Abgeordnete, die auch kein Englisch sprechen müssen, auch in der Lage sein, ähm die Gesetzestexte selber zu lesen, um sich selber ein Urteil zu bilden und äh deswegen passiert diese Abstimmung
Vermute ich jetzt mal stark auf den äh noch nicht vom League-Service bereinigten Texten, die übersetzt wurden schon bevor
Dieses Liegeservice daran gearbeitet hat, weil die Übersetzung dauert ja einige Zeit in all diesen Sprachen und äh
Dadurch ergibt erklärt sich das für mich, ja? Aber hundertprozentig sicher weiß ich nicht, wieso der Artikel dreizehn da noch nicht seinen neuen Namen, Artikel siebzehn hat. Ähm ich bin aber auch recht hap.
Nee, aber das das ist eine überzeugende Erklärung.
Ähm aber.
Genau, auf jeden Fall Artikel äh dreizehn, Artikel elf, wenn wir die hier rausgestrichen bekommen, dann ist es eine ähm Urheberrechtsreform, die man aus meiner Sicht annehmen kann, die immer noch Verbesserungen bringt und die vor allem diesen enormen Kollateralschaden nicht hat,
Das ist das positive Outcome, damit können wir gut leben, glaube ich und das wäre ein enormer Erfolg für die letzpolitische Bewegung,
in Europa für den Fall, dass wir verlieren, gibt's noch einen letzten Weg, wie wir das Ding verhindern können.
Mann, immer nochmal einen. Komm, jetzt ist aber langsam Ruhe. Wir haben.
Das ist ich weiß.
Monaten, seit seit anderthalb Jahren haben wir Upload-Filter im Logbuchnetzpolitiker. Wie oft war das jetzt die letzte Chance?
Ähm das das im Plenum ist die letzte äh,
Wirklich gut realistische Chance, die letzte, wo wir auf inhaltlicher A Basis noch äh argumentieren können und äh,
ja, aber formal gesehen gibt's noch eine letzte Mög.
Welche ist das? Welche.
Und zwar.
Veto durch Donald Trump oder.
Nein, wehtut durch Deutschland? Ähm und zwar der Text ist im Raten nämlich durch den äh äh Rechtsausschuss durchgegangen. Äh dort hat
Katharina Barley. Ähm bald Spitzenkandidaten der SPD in der Europawahl. Jetzt noch Ministerin äh dem Ganzen zugestimmt, was kein Mensch verstanden hat. Ähm obwohl sie jetzt dagegen ist, sie hätte es verhindern können
Äh und äh das war aber eben nur der Rechtsausschuss. Es braucht danach noch ein finales Zustimmen.
Auch zu dem eben rechtlich abgeänderten Text mit den Finalen Verfeinerungen
und diese Abstimmung wird wahrscheinlich äh lass mich jetzt nicht lügen, ich glaube es war der sechste oder neunte April im Rat stattfinden und im Moment ist es so.
Gegen dieses Gesetz sind Italien, Polen und Niederlande,
Wenn Deutschland sich diesen Ländern anschließt, dann hätten wir äh vierzig Prozent äh der EU-Bevölkerung, die dagegen wehren und damit kann das Gesetz nicht beschlossen werden.
Diese Entscheidung im Rat wird aber nicht von Katharina Bade getroffen, sondern höchstwahrscheinlich von irgendeinem anderen der Minister, der halt dabei diesem Ratstermin äh
zuständig ist, anwesend ist, es ist eben keine thematisches Durchwinken, sondern sozusagen wirklich die Person, die da ist. Das kann auch ein Minister von der Union sein.
Aber die deutsche Bundesregierung kann an dieser Stelle auch Anfang April nochmal auf die Bremse steigen und dieses Gesetz verhindern. Das ist nicht wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist sozusagen.
Nee, nein, das ist nicht wahrscheinlich.
Wir, es ist ja unser Job, all diese Formalien.
Die aller allerletzte, versprochen ihren Wort. Wenn das durchgeht, wirklich nichts mehr, dann ist es durch.
Aber das heißt ja, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ähm am Ende ist es dann doch wieder die SPD, die ist verkackt.
Ja, ich meine, sie können Regierungsbruch ähm ja, ich meine, sie können sich auf das Koalitionsabkommen berufen.
Sie können sich auf den Koalitionsvertrag berufen und damit eine Regierungskrise auslösen.
Ja, davor wehrhalt Katharina Barley das Bornopfer gewesen, wenn Michael sie rauswirft wegen ihrem ähm,
ist nicht durchgibstrecht wegen ihrem Weisungsrecht, ähm dann dann wäre sie die Richtlinienkompetenz Danke. Dann wäre sie die perfekte Spitzenkandidatin für die SPD gewesen, weil dann ist sie die, die aufgestanden
gegen Uploadfiltern. Und äh ich meine, sie ist ja sowieso ab Mai keine Ministerin mehr. Also, sie hätte nicht viel verloren, aber viel gewonnen. Die Kalkulation ähm,
hat's ihnen so nicht getroffen. Äh jetzt wissen wir nicht, wer die Entscheidung treffen wird, aber wahrscheinlich wird's weiterhin Schreibsache sein. Und äh ich ich ehrlich gesagt will ich,
nicht unbedingt, dass es am Ende wieder an Deutschland hängt. Ich hätte gerne eine Abstimmung, die im Plenum des Europaparlaments von den direkt gewählten Leut.
Innen brei.
Genau, das ist auf jeden Fall auch die die stärkere Verankerung dieser Grundsatzentscheidung gegen Uploadfilter, die ich glaube, die werden nicht erreichen, wenn wir den Dreizehner rausgestrichen bekommen nächsten Dienstag.
Ähm wenn es im Rat vereppt, dann wär's irgendwie,
Nicht ganz so sauber, nicht ganz so symbolträchtig, aber es wäre immer noch ein ein Signal und es würde reichen, dieses Gesetz zu verhindern. Die Reform wäre dann,
Tod, ja? Genauso fast wie sie, wenn sie einfach im im Parlament, wenn am Ende nochmal dagegen gestimmt wird. Ähm,
ja. Also das letzte Mal vor sowas passiert ist, war in den Neunzigern. Ähm bei der bei dem Fight äh.
Um die EU Softwarepatente haben wir es auch geschafft das im Rat im letzten Moment noch zu verhindern nachdem es schon irgendwie das Parlament durch war und alles fix fertig und das Gesetz lag
X-Wettic da und dann haben wir es nochmal im letzten Metern im Rad über so eine Sperr äh äh Minderheit, die im Grunde verhindert
Ähm also wir wir reden hier schon wirklich von den Tricks, die wir ganz tief im Ärmel haben, ne? Aber weil das hier ein Podcast mit
vielen deutschsprachigen Hörerinnen und Hörern ist, dachte ich mir, es wäre wichtig, auch noch darauf hinzuweisen, sozusagen für den allerschlimmsten Fall, dass wir wirklich am Dienstag verlieren, was ich wirklich, wirklich nicht hoffe und inzwischen auch
nicht mehr wirklich glaube fast. Ähm.
Ich sehe zumindest Hoffnung, aber wenn wir's wirklich nicht schaffen, am Dienstag, dann muss alles in Richtung Bundesregierung und äh Solum und Comora, es muss den Leuten klar sein, das dürfte ihnen nicht passieren lassen,
weil das ist dann unser allerletzte Defensler.
Diese allerletzten Defense-Lions, das ist schon echt interessant, dass das in den EU Sachen irgendwie dann doch viel viel öfter ist, als in den ähm.
Bundestagsgeschichten. Liegt aber vielleicht auch daran, dass wir seit so langer Zeit eine äh große Koalition haben.
Kinos, ich glaube absolut nicht der einzige Grund, wieso sich das national anders anfühlt ist, weil,
Ist dort ein Fraktionszwang gibt und die eigentliche Entscheidung schon so viel im Vorfeld außerhalb von allen Kameras und allen öffentlichen Debatten und bekannten Änderungsanträgen passiert,
Europa ist einfach nur transparent. Deswegen sehen wir irgendwie die Social Creation, wie sich das da durch die Röhre durchwülst und wie sehr es stinkt und wie viel äh.
Der dieling da vielleicht noch drinnen ist, äh dass es national genauso schlimm. Wir kriegen's noch nicht mit.
Ich habe äh gelernt, dass das Zitat wird oft wem nochmal zugesagt. Bis Mark oder wem auch immer, ist auf jeden Fall falsch. Ähm.
Das Zitat lautet ja von von Gesetzen und Würsten will man nicht wissen, wie sie gemacht werden.
Und ähm im Rahmen dieser EU-Urheberrechtsreform habe ich auf jeden Fall den Eindru.
Der Axel Voss, der hat noch nicht mal eine Wurstfabrik.
Ähm ja, ich glaube äh an an ihm wird's nicht hängen. Es sind äh im Moment mache ich mir Sorgen, um die Sozialdemokratie,
weil die Sozialdemokraten haben am Mittwoch die Entscheidung getroffen, dass sie für das Gesetz sind, für die Orhaberrechtsrichtlinie oder irgendwelchen Änderungen?
Ähm scheinbar war es am Mittwoch so, dass einfach äh die die Befürworter vor allem aus Frankreich alle zahlreich da waren und äh die progressiven Kräfte einfach nicht bei dieser Fraktionssitzung waren und dann hatte man eine Mehrheit dafür und das heißt auch, dass da ähm
obwohl sie eigentlich ein klassischer Viehboot ist. Die Leute sind gespalten und man muss jetzt sozusagen ähm
es wirklich den einzelnen Abgeordneten überlassen. Trotzdem gibt die Partei ja immer noch eine Empfehlung ab
und wenn ich mich als Abgeordneter nicht damit beschäftige, ist diese Empfehlung meiner Partei in ganz vielen Fällen alles an Informationen, was ich mir anschaue.
Und das ist vor allem eben in den nicht deutschsprachigen Ländern,
Probleme im Moment, dass man an dieser Sozialdemokraten noch herantreten muss und und die vor allem nochmal jetzt äh informieren darüber, dass es da massive Proteste gab in ganz Europa mit zweihunderttausend Leuten
all die Argumente, die wir heute genannt und auch verlinken werden. Ähm das
Wer so für Montag, wo man ja noch anrufen kann, äh wenn man's nicht so, wie mein Kollege Bernhard nach Straßburg schafft und ihm Personen nochmal Klinken putzt, dann wär's sinnvoll, ähm da jetzt mindestens nochmal anzurufen, am Montag zur Büroöffnungszeiten
und äh ja daran daran kann's wirklich noch scheitern oder? Wir gewinnen am Dienstag. Mal schauen.
Viele, die diese Sendung hören werden, die vielleicht sogar schon nach Dienstag hören. Äh ich muss jetzt echt noch zusehen, die zu veröffentlichen.
Ähm deswegen werde ich gleich mal die Chapter Marx opfern und versuchen, das noch irgendwie so rauszuhauen. Ähm ich habe gerade schon gesagt, wir schmeißen einfach alle anderen Themen raus und liefern sie zeitnah nach.
Am besten in der kommenden Woche.
Und am besten sehr schnell, weil sonst haben wir wieder so einen Themenstau, das ist dann auch nicht gut. Ähm es kommen ja immer wieder neue Themen.
Ja, es gibt doch keinen Sauerstoff mehr für andere Themen neben Urheberrechtsgerade.
Ja, aber bei mir gibt's auch echt langsam keinen Sauerstoff mehr für das Thema, muss ich echt sagen. Also ich habe ähm also ich bin auch froh, dass es jetzt dann hoffentlich vorbei ist.
Muss ich, muss ich jetzt mal so persönlich sagen, so ich habe da also ist jetzt vielleicht auch noch Spätfolge von meinem Brüsselbesuch, ja? Ich habe ja schon angedeutet, der hat mir wirklich den Schlaf geraubt. Ähm.
Ich wäre jetzt froh, wenn wir dieses Thema jetzt äh adActa legen können. Puntenten und ähm.
Hoffentlich in weiteren politischen Themen.
Auf bessere politische Arbeit unserer Vertreterinnen und Vertreter setzen können und gleichzeitig diese Energie, die wir jetzt mal zusammen hatten.
In der Gesellschaft, in der Bewegung. Ähm in irgendeiner Weise aufrecht erhalten und in positive Richtungen schieben, ja?
Das wäre gerade so ein bisschen ausgefranst, das ist halt meine Sorge.
Dass das einfach die Leute verkrätzt, ja, dass die Politikverdrossenheit zunimmt und das ist wicht.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, unabhängig davon, wie.
Dieses Thema ausgehen wird. Ich hoffe, es ist allen Leuten nochmal sehr viel bewusster geworden, wie wichtig es ist am fünfundzwanzigsten Mai zur Europawahl zu gehen.
Und und wir dürfen nicht irgendwie die schlechtesten Politiker in Europa mit dem europäischen Projekt gleichsetzen. Das das.
Er mir noch wichtig, aber jetzt schauen wir mal, wir werden's wissen. Die meisten Leute werden schon wissen, wenn sie diesen Podcast hören und werden sich noch fragen, was wir für Vollidioten sind. Äh insofern ist es wahrscheinlich auch gut, diese Sendung jetzt zu äh beenden und ähm
äh wirst das nächste Mal hören, dann wissen wir, was passiert ist.
Aber man merkt auch, muss ich äh muss ich abschließend kurz sagen, man merkt wirklich, dass wir beide ähm lange Wochen und Wochenenden hinter uns haben und jetzt hier noch am Sonntag gesagt haben, wir machen noch kurze Sendung, ich habe den Thomas am Anfang,
Eingeredet, ich will das nur kurz machen, wir wir schildern kurz unsere Eindrücke. Ähm das ist ein Fluch, der auf Lokbuch Netzpolitik lastet. Immer wenn ich sage, das muss hier mal flott gehen.
Dann setzen wir äh Rekorde in der Dauer. Ähm ich danke dir Thomas jetzt schon.
Nicht nur für deine dein Engagement hier am Sonntagabend, sondern vor allem für die.
Mühe, die du diesem Thema gewidmet hast. Über ein Jahr ähm hast du das hier verfolgt.
Du hast es auch hier im im Logbuch immer.
Mehr und kompetenter eingebracht als ich. Du hast mir immer regelmäßig Bescheid gesagt und in den Ohren gelegen, hier Uploadfilter wichtig. Äh, Julia, anrufen, Julia lesen, Julia in die Sendung holen, ähm.
Und ich denke, was du jetzt auch heute nochmal geschildert hast so über das Engagement mit äh Plätsch zwanzig neunzehn,
mit dem Reisen nach Brüssel ähm das ist äh wirklich beeindruckend und.
Ich finde das immer äh großartig mit dir darüber zu sprechen,
und zu sehen, was du da machst und ähm auf die Beine stellst und dir Gedanken machst und wie du das alles verstehst. Also da muss ich einfach mal jetzt auch an dieser Stelle dir danken, bevor.
Ich direkt zum weiteren Dank übergehe, um diese äh Orkur Situation jetzt zu überspielen.
Okay, ich sage, ich sage jetzt nichts mehr. Ich bin jetzt nur noch still die ganze Sendung.
Genau, ich danke. Ich danke ähm
erstmal allen, die zu den Demonstrationen gegangen sind. Ich hoffe
ihr fühlt euch mit eurem Engagement jetzt nicht übergangen, weil wir hier viel über äh Wien und Berlin gesprochen haben. Ich weiß es waren insgesamt über fünfzig Orte. Wir konnten jetzt nur von den beiden sprechen. Ähm.
Ich find's umso cooler, dass irgendwie in Paderborn und in auch also die ganzen kleinen Demos, die sind eigentlich die.
Ebenso wichtigen.
Und die auch zeigen, auf welcher Breite das steht, ja? Dass in so vielen Städten Engagement da war, in so vielen Städten Menschen auf die Straße mobilisiert wurden, die ja auch alle.
Irgendwie,
ähm äh organisiert und äh von der Infrastruktur aufgebaut wurden, ja? Und äh diesen Menschen, die da an den in den vergangenen Wochen und insbesondere an diesem Wochenende Arbeit geleistet haben, möchte ich danken.
Und dann danke ich Christian.
Christian, Arnold, sehr verspätet.
Und trotzdem herzlich und ganz besonders danke ich Thomas, aber nicht du, sondern der Hörer Thomas, dem ähm auch sehr herzlich.
Gedankt ist an dieser St.
Nochmal schnell. Ich danke den Organisatoren von diesen ganzen Demos. Ähm da waren ja einige dabei, die das zum ersten Mal gemacht haben und ich finde das wahnsinnig,
Danke und ich danke auch noch irgendwie dem ganzen Team von Ebicenter Works, ohne die ich ähm nichts von dem schaffen könnte. Was, was da so passiert, wo wir einen kleinen Anteil leisten können,
So, das war eine lange Sendung. Bis bald.
Ja. Ciao ciao.